that what you did here today absolutely
not okay
why wasn't this instructor
terminated for filing a false report
that this is his report there's nothing
in it that's false isn't it true that
you believe he wasn't funny because he
did nothing wrong
he did nothing wrong
correct okay uh
and there was no cover-up by Deer Valley
correct absolutely not great no further
questions thank you
thank you Mr Sykes
good to see you again Mr Graf thank you
for coming back thank you very nice of
you
it was cooperating yesterday
I think I just need to go back to the
old technology again
Okay so
just want to ask you you Mr Graf
one question
oh yeah go ahead
I just want to ask you Mr Graf a quick
question about the patrol log
um published this we looked at it
yesterday with you defendants exhibit
26a
you were asked questions not today but
before you left the stand Yesterday by
plaintiff's cancel
about this uh bad boot uh entry here do
you see that I do see that and I uh um
do you remember questions about how that
was sort of a a minor issue and and he
was asking why that would be long but
other major issues might not be yes so
can you explain what is a bad boot it
and what would it require of a patrol uh
patroller Who Came Upon that kind of a
problem you know I'm not
exactly sure what this bad boot issue
was but um
it could be that the Buckle was broken
it could be that
as funny as it sounds could be there on
the wrong feet you know you see things
like that so there was some issue that
just responded to and it was as simple
as a bad Boot and made it required a
toboggan down the hill if someone had a
malfunction that they they couldn't get
down the hill yes okay so
um and then this this section here 1202
again I'll use this little laser pointer
1202 here
um
it
over in the nature of the injury
discussion it says here collision and
disorientation
do you know who wrote that
I don't know who wrote it whoever is
Manning the dispatch is the person who
who puts these entries in okay so would
would it be fair to say then that it
would not be Whitney Smith that wrote
that they would not be Whitney Smith
they're transcribing what Whitney Smith
is saying over the radio so Whitney
Smith was on scene two minutes after the
call came in
um
and then whoever was there
wrote down what she said Okay and she
said that she was on scene of a skier
collision with the patient experiencing
disorientation right and and the jury
has heard where her experience was and
you don't know anything further than
you've already told us about that
correct that's correct okay thank you
no further questions all right you were
excused thank you thank you is it there
a possibility the witness may be called
back
a very small okay so you're still under
uh I guess this trial so please don't
discuss the case with any of the other
Witnesses okay thank you
Mr Owens is your next witness ready
yes our next witness is Dr sure we we
need an easel and to set up for him to
draw and we may need a second to do that
okay okay
go ahead and set up
Dr Cher
good morning come on forward here and be
sworn in as a witness
do you swear that the testimony you are
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
God
adjust your microphone and then please
State your full name and spell it all
out for us
thank you
my name is Irving sure Irv ing last name
is s-c-h-e-r
thank you for being with us here today
Dr sure
um let's let's begin by just asking you
what you understand your role here to be
today
to teach the jury about biomechanical
engineering related to snow Sports and
particular skiing
and uh
do you have an understanding of what
plaintiff's biomechanical expert Dr Bain
has said about this case I have I've
read his deposition testimony and his
trial testimony so I do understand what
he's saying in the case yes okay and you
have opinions about his testimony is
that right that is correct I've analyzed
his biomechanical engineering analysis
so the jury will get to hear your
response to his analysis exactly okay
great so before we get to that let's
talk about your background in training
so they understand why uh
you and not me are I understand sure um
so uh where did you go to school
I did my Bachelor's of Science and
Engineering at the University of
Pennsylvania I majored in mechanical
engineering and applied mechanics
and then after undergrad I moved West
and I got my masters and my PhD at UC
Berkeley in the mechanical engineering
department and I had two disciplines
that I specialized in one was called
Dynamic systems that's how objects move
in space when forces are applied to them
and the other is biomechanical
engineering and that is the application
of physics and Engineering to the human
body in particular looking at how people
get injured and how to prevent injuries
and did you do a PhD thesis I did and
can you explain what you worked on sure
um I was the last in the line of what we
call skeologists I studied the
biomechanics of Alpine skiing I created
load cells so those are devices that
measure the forces
and I put them in between the skis and
the bindings and I had different
instrumentation on skiers and it was the
first time or at least that I'm aware of
that we were anyone in the scientific
Community was able to measure the forces
and the body motions of skiers from the
top of the mountain all the way down to
the bottom and I did this with beginners
people who had only skied two or three
days in their whole life all the way up
to professional Racers and so that's
what I got my PhD in and this is
actually measurements on the slope as
people are skiing that's right exactly
yeah I'm measuring the forces applied to
the person and their body motions as
they're skiing well and falling we did
have Falls as well right and so this is
not just calculations in some Ivory
Tower but you're actually out in the
field looking at Hands-On work which is
quite difficult when you have
electronics and snow and water and it
was challenging for sure
and do you also do any teaching I did
teach after I graduated with my PhD I
did a small postdoc in the biology
department at Berkeley and then after
that while I was working for a company I
taught at the University of Southern
California I was in the physical therapy
department on the Medical Campus and I
taught intro to biomechanics and I also
did research there at USC and then I
moved I now live in Seattle and I'm at
the University of Washington I have an
affiliate professorship there I'm an
associate affiliate associate professor
at the University of Washington and I
occasionally lecture but mostly advise
grad students
what about uh professional licenses do
you have any of those
I'm a registered professional mechanical
engineer in California Washington and
Alaska
and then in terms of
professional societies these groups of
people that get together to research and
work on a certain field are you
connected to any such organizations I am
and what are those
I am chair of a group called ASTM f27 if
you've ever gone to a ski shop and
purchased ski equipment or rented ski
equipment and they set your bindings
with some people call Din settings
that's based on the standards from ASTM
and I'm the chairman of that group we
also do other snow sports equipment I
represent the US for snow sports
equipment safety at the international
standards organization so the iso so if
you go over to Europe you'll have the
same release and retention settings for
your skis your your bindings won't pull
off your skis they use the same
standards that we've developed here in
the U.S
I'm also president of a group called The
International Society for snow Sports
safety and that's more academic than the
other two organizations I was mentioning
we call it i s s i Triple S is the
Premier organization worldwide to
present and publish your snowsport
safety research and we have members from
all over the world Switzerland Korea
Norway obviously the US Canada Australia
New Zealand it's uh it's quite a great
group and it's really the group that
helped develop ski binding standards
so you do some research on
the safety of snow sports like skiing
correct that is my main focus of my
research ever since grad school and I've
continued to do that now
and then you you also value a cases in a
litigation context is that right I do
about
15 20 of my work is a forensic work the
rest is research and development
so most of the time
are you doing research to try to try and
improve the safety of skiers on the hill
yes and I should say it's not just snow
Sports I work in other Recreational
Sports areas water sports mountain
biking other areas too but snow Sports
is my my favorite my passion
so let's explain to the jury what by
biomechanical engineering is just
because we could use a refresher
ensure biomechanical engineering is the
application of physics and mechanical
engineering to the human body but in a
forensic sense it's what links the event
to the injury so if you have some type
of event and there's forces and motions
in the event in the accident the forces
are applied to a person there's internal
forces on the like in their body at the
joints or something like that
the amount of force and the amount of
motion it takes to create damage to the
body that is biomechanical engineering
how is that different than medicine
they're both dealing with the human body
but what's the difference sure the
medical field tends to take the injured
person figure out what's wrong with them
so diagnosis and then try to get them
better so treatment with an eventual
outcome so most medical training is
after the injury as opposed to what
forces and motions create the injury we
like to think of ourselves on different
sides of the injury
can biomechanical Engineers determine
the forces required to produce fractures
of bones in the body yes there's a lot
of research on that and that's one of
the main areas for biomechanical
engineering
so is there scientific literature that
describes the forces needed for say rib
fractures there is yes and you're
familiar with that literature I am yes
and uh
let's let's maybe ask a specific
question about that literature given
your knowledge of it does a 70 year old
man need to fall on his side uh with his
elbow between him and the ground to
cause rib fractures
no so there have been a number of
scientific studies mostly done by
biomechanical Engineers but there's
other scientists who have looked at this
as well and what they do is they take
cadavers or portions of cadavers and
they apply forces to them sometimes
they'll swing a pendulum into the side
of a cadaver or into the front or
they'll have a plate a very heavy
weighted plate contact the person arm
down arm up at 45 degrees or they'll
drop the cadaver in different
configurations and then they'll see what
injuries are produced and so when
they've done this in particular for
chest impacts what we find is you can
get lateral rib fractures according to
the biomechanical engineering literature
you can get lateral rib fractures with a
an impact to the side with your arm down
or with your arm up but you can also get
lateral rib fractures from compression
so front to back compression
of the chest so if I press my chest in
like this what happens is the ribs
actually Bend out on the side and that
can create fractures on the side and
that's quite common as well so rib
fractures are not just from side contact
it can be from front to back compression
as well
so
um
let's get to
um What You Did In this case so what did
I ask you to do in this case
basically you asked me to evaluate Dr
Van's biomechanical engineering analysis
to see if it was accurate and correct
and what material did you review I think
you already mentioned you read his
transcript and you watched his trial
testimonies I did I did yes and maybe
for the jury in case they need a
reminder he had that green screen in the
back of him right just the talking head
speaking from Florida I think that's
right right and so let's uh just start
with his analysis do you agree with it
I do not I do not agree with his
analysis and maybe uh before we explain
why just give us a sense of what you
believe what you understand his method
and Analysis to be
sure
um as I've gone through what he
testified to and his deposition in the
trial looking at his calculations and
what he's done
to me there's two parts to his analysis
the first is calculations to show that
Miss Paltrow had to land on Mr Sanderson
in order to get the rib fractures that
he got
and then there was a second part that
basically said
um because Miss Paltrow had to land on
Miss Mr Sanderson that could only happen
with Miss Paltrow hitting him from
behind it couldn't happen any other way
it was impossible so that's my
understanding of the the kind of the two
parts the main parts thank you we'll go
in those go over those in more detail as
you looked at his analysis you read
everything that he read correct I did
and did you read even more than that I
had additional depositions that's
correct of the various people that were
at the scene of the accident that's
right
um
so
let's get one thing out of the way do
you agree with Dr Bain that Mr
sanderson's Root practice did not occur
during the initials here to skier
contact yes I think that that's correct
there's no disagreement at this point at
least from the testimony I've heard the
skier skier portion where they first
Contact no matter which version we have
did not create the rib fractures I don't
think anyone thinks that at this point
so that's good we we agree
and um
in terms of just a quick overview before
we go into his calculations which you
can explain to the jury
do you believe that Miss Paltrow's
account and I should say are you
familiar with her account I am and you
heard her trial testimony I did and read
her deposition and do you believe her
account of the Collision is consistent
with biome what you know about Hill
mechanical engineering object
goes beyond the scope of this expert
witness
would you please approach the bench
sure
okay so let's go back to that question
I was asking you in your opinion is Miss
Paltrow's account consistent with what
you know about biomechanical engineering
yes it is and maybe another way to put
that
um
is is it consistent with the laws of
physics
it's the same question yes yeah exactly
Dr Bain the jury heard talked a lot
about Newton's laws and the laws of
physics applying those to the evidence
in this case and again in your analysis
as you apply them Miss Paltrow's
um
account is consistent with those
objection logs Foundation
overruled
that's correct her Miss Paltrow's
version her her scenario is consistent
with the laws of physics and what we
know about biomechanics
and then the account that Dr Bain gave
that is based on Mr Ramon's account
is that consistent with the laws of
physics
I do not believe it is and I can
as we get into it yes okay great we'll
we'll explain that let's
let's um
go to Dr beam's calculations so you can
explain to the jury
um your analysis of those I'm we can we
have an easel and as I understand it you
you would like to come draw so that you
can show them what the equations mean is
that correct that's exactly right okay
so I'll grab the easel and then that
board
we can't block the judge
judge where do you want this season on
the screen he's going to also need to
see the screen so is it okay if we put
it
right here are you going to be able to
see that
I can't see it but it's really more
important that the juries see it so I'm
fine with that okay
if you're okay with the judge you can
do this
okay so I'm gonna pull up
something that Dr Bain pulled up uh in
his deposition
do you remember seeing
these documents and for the record and
for Council these are
um
the notes in exhibit three of Dr Bain's
deposition
thank you
I missed the question there yeah no
you're fine so I'm just pointing you
before you uh what these are not
admitted exhibits though yeah I'm not
asking them to be admitted they were
just shown in Dr Bain's deposition so
we're showing them here as well
okay but not in his trial testimony
he's responding to these you said
deposition
he also showed it in his trial testimony
oh trial deposition yeah
yeah let's just say direct things to the
judge but I I recalled I recall this
being flashed the strongest deposition
or during his trial testimony
okay thank you Dr sure so you recognize
this page
I I do and I was just describing it this
was shown in Dr Bain's trial testimony
correct that's correct and he explained
that these are his calculations that's
right okay and there's another page as
well I think it's the one just before it
correct that's correct this is where he
starts the calculations for the ribs
we're concentrating on the ribs here
because that's what he says determines
how the the accident happened he said
the head injury doesn't matter for that
it's only the ribs okay great so since I
have very little idea what's going on
there and you do maybe explain to the
jury what's going on sure can we go to
the page before this sure
and maybe if you it's just a little bit
hard to hear sorry is that better yeah
okay A little better yeah thanks
um so he's using some basic equations
for what we call the center of Mass to
figure out what happens when someone
falls to the ground Center of mass is if
you were to balance someone on your
finger the point that you'd hold them at
so that they stay balanced
usually a little bit below your belly
button kind of midline front to back
midline left to right and so if you took
the person's all the person's weight all
the person's mass and put it into one
point that would be the point that
you're interested in so that's what Dr
Bame is doing in these calculations is
he's using that point for Mr Sanderson
and this first part here
where he has
this
that's an equation x is positioned so
he's saying there's a certain distance
that Center of mass Falls and you can
see that over here that's three and a
half feet or he does it in meters
1.0668 meters so Center of mass falls to
the ground he's saying that there's no
initial
falling position that that's fine no
initial falling velocity V is velocity
and then he has one half acceleration
times time squared and that equation is
correct acceleration here is the
acceleration from Gravity so what he's
saying is Mr sanderson's fall to the
ground for the center of Mass from three
and a half feet
probably about right
hits the ground within and he calculates
the time he solves for time
0.466 seconds
so that's the first part of that which
is great
the problem comes in that he then says
the velocity at contact is one half
acceleration times time
and that is absolutely wrong that is not
the velocity at contact the velocity at
contact
is just the acceleration times time so
he has this extra half
and it was unclear to me why that would
be there to start and I'm not sure why
you put that in but it creates problems
for his calculations and his opinions
moving forward if we can go to the next
page I can explain that
so these are his equations if you
remember in his testimony he said 4 000
Newtons and that's an engineering unit
in in metric for Force four thousand
Newtons is roughly 950 pounds I think in
English but Newton's is fine over 4 000
Newtons you get the rip fractures
so what is this equation here I'll show
you that and then explain why that
one-half makes a big difference so that
equation there comes from at first
kinetic energy
label that as ke which is equal to
one half
mass times velocity squared for that
Center of mass
and then he's saying okay Mr Sanderson
as he hits the ground has a certain
kinetic energy that energy has to go
somewhere
so what happens is a force is applied
from the ground to a center of mass and
he decelerates over some distance so you
can see here he has three inches written
here that that's important so
this kinetic energy has to be taken up
by some Force
over a distance that's some amount of
work
and that will equal
kinetic energy and then he divides both
sides to get the force
the distances cancel on this side so the
force on Mr Sanderson is one half
mass times velocity squared divided by
distance and that's exactly what we have
here we have one half
Mass velocity squared and distance
now
remember he's doing this in metric so
that 136
that is in kilograms
that's equal to about 300 pounds
so here he has
Miss Paltrow and Mr sanderson's Mass put
together so in this fall he's saying
okay the kinetic energy of both of them
is needed here
during contact
but
can we go back to page five
he uses the velocity here
0.29 that has the one half in this so if
we go to the next page yeah so you can
see he's using the wrong velocity what
happens is if you use the wrong velocity
in here let's do
beams as call this wrong
so what you get is one half mass times
one half acceleration times time
there we go divided by distance and
right there
correct
is one half Mass
acceleration times time squared so that
one half goes into this equation what
does that mean that means that this half
gets squared it becomes 1 4.
so the force that
Dr beam calculated for this Landing was
actually one-fourth of the force he
should have calculated he was off by a
factor of four
so it shouldn't be
4680 Newtons it should be eighteen
thousand six hundred and some Newtons
actually I have it here
um eighteen thousand six hundred and
seventy eight Newtons so he's off by
quite a bit and if I made Dr sure what
this is obviously all uh uh at least new
to me and maybe new to some jurors what
in the end uh is the takeaway there if
there's that much of a mistake so
there's there's two things one is if
there were eighteen thousand Newtons
applied to Mr sanderson's chest we would
expect much worse injuries the
biomechanical engineering literature for
much less than that has many more rib
fractures internal injuries all sorts of
things we don't see any of that for Mr
Sanderson
but the real takeaway and the importance
in this case is the mass here so because
he does the one quarter he needs the
mass
he needs the mass to be 136 kilograms
now if you redo the calculations
correctly
with with just Mr sanderson's Mass so
Mr Sanderson is about
80 and a half kilograms or roughly
177 pounds at least according to
the medical records
if you do the calculations with the
correct equations
and only his Mass
you get over 4 000 Newtons when he lands
actually
you get
11 056 Newtons so if you were to fall to
the snow
using Dr beam's calculation method the
correct way
then just Mr Sanderson falling not miss
Paltrow involved at all he could get rib
fractures
this is not quite correct overall
normally we use what's called effective
Mass so all of Mr sanderson's Mass
wouldn't go through his chest maybe
there'd be some force on his legs if he
hit his head some force on his head we
typically would say maybe 50 of his Mass
would be appropriate for Effective Mass
so instead of the 80 kilograms we would
do
and actually I should put over here this
winds up being
eleven thousand
Newtons and if we do the 40 kilograms
instead for Mr Sanderson so
and that's a
and we use the correct equation we get
sorry I don't do the math in my head
five thousand
500 Newtons approximately
what this means is Mr Sanderson can fall
to the ground without Miss Paltrow
landing on him
and sustain the rib fractures according
to Dr bame's calculation method
so if done correctly he cannot say his
opinion that Miss Paltrow had to land on
Mr Sanderson to get the rib fractures
which means that this goes through the
rest of his analysis so the rest of his
analysis is wrong
so this is really critical that one half
that that he did for the velocity
the wrong velocity really through the
rest of his analysis into question so
doctor sure there's a lot more we could
say about the calculations I'm sure and
you would you would approach it
differently than he did correct that's
correct but
given the way he did it if he did it
correctly you're saying that the um the
conclusions that he came to are
inconsistent with his opinion that's
correct yes okay exactly
Okay so
um yeah
okay Doctor let's talk about
um
let's talk about skier skier collisions
you've as you explained earlier I've
done research to
understand what forces are like on the
ski slope so
um in this case how how would you apply
what you know about physics to
understand the claims about this key
Collision
sure I would apply Newton's laws to the
contacts the different versions of the
events and see
what makes sense how it would unfold do
the physics of the contact that's being
testified to makes sense is it
self-consistent
and this this may be another opportunity
to draw some pictures if you need to so
feel free to if it will help you but
um you were talking about the center of
mass earlier how does that
concept factor into how you would
evaluate the evidence in this case sure
yet if it's okay to draw again you may
thank you
oh nice perfect great
and if you need more uh board or Pages
we have them now is that correct
okay yeah great go ahead
so the thing to know with Newton's Laws
Force equals mass times acceleration if
you have some and I'm going to draw two
versions of a skier and I'm not the best
Pictionary player I'm going to draw a
top-down version and I'll draw a side
version so let's start with the top down
so if we have a skier
and here's the skier's head and here's
the skier's nose and then we have two
skis
the center of mass would be
as we mentioned looking down somewhere
around here
now if you have a force that goes
through the center of mass so say the
force
goes through
then the person will accelerate in this
direction they'll accelerate along the
line of the force
but what happens when you have a force
that doesn't go through the center of
mass
it'll create an acceleration going that
same direction but it'll also
distance here it'll also create a torque
which is equal to the force times the
distance that will cause the person to
rotate
and that's really important because if
the force does not go through the center
of mass there's always a rotation
so if you're hit on the this looking
down this would be the right side then
the person is going to rotate
counterclockwise in this image the same
thing is true if we look at a skier from
the side
so here we have our
skier
and here's their pelvis
and
Center of mass
ski boot
and if the person for example has a
force applied
below their Center of mass
then there's again some distance that's
going to create
a torque and a backward rotation so that
the person moves
backward
and falls back
um
there's two things to note with this for
skiing in particular that's different
than most other events
skis have releasable bindings so if I'm
looking at this side view
the boot is held in
by a heel piece and a toe piece and so
if you have someone pitching forward if
the ski slows
in person's Center of mass moves forward
it'll create a torque on the boot and
it'll release
the heel of the boot
and for someone of Miss Paltrow size
that could be
anywhere from well it's approximately
143 foot-pounds so 143 pounds acting
over a foot
um
same thing is true for the top down view
if we look at the toe piece for the
binding if there's a torque
on on the skia twisting torque
the ski will also release from the boot
and for someone of Miss Paltrow's size
it's about 37 foot-pounds so in front of
the boot if there's 37 pounds one foot
ahead it it'll release if it's two feet
ahead it's half that value so roughly
17. so these are the principles that we
need to understand the mechanics of an
impact in a fall so when we apply those
principles to this case what conclusions
do you draw
sure the first is that Miss Paltrow's
version of events is consistent with the
laws of physics and how people move and
rotate
and uh
what about Mr Ramon's version for Mr
Ramon's version I couldn't get it to
work
and there's it doesn't match with the
laws of physics the the complete part of
his testimony just doesn't fit and so
can you explain why it doesn't fit
uh sure so uh Mr Ramon's version
oh maybe I should sit down oh sure yeah
go ahead
so uh in Mr Ramon's version
he says that he sees Miss Paltrow
contact
UM
Mr Sanderson squarely in the back
and he says that it's in the middle it
couldn't be any more in the middle than
if he tried or if he tried and then also
that she wrote him down I think the
quote was something like in his
deposition he says like she wouldn't
couldn't have been on his back any more
than if he had strapped her to his back
something like that
so as they're going down in Mr Ramon's
version uh Mr Sanderson goes spread
eagle
arms out legs out and the key for me is
that Mr sander I'm sorry Mr Ramon says
that the inside edges of those skis that
are going into this V catch and Mr
Sanderson stops on a dime
and if that were the case then miss
Paltrow would keep moving and well maybe
I should draw sure go ahead if it will
yeah I think so
okay so uh I'm gonna try to draw a
top-down version of this so if we have
Mr Sanderson
and
here are his skis
and then I'm going to use a different
color for Miss Paltrow how about blue
Miss Paltrow
contacts him
from the back
and now
this is the same whether one ski is
between his or or both skis
it the skis are apart it's a little bit
different so we can get to that in a
minute but if if her skis are between
his
let's just say
than when he falls
and here is his
so they're moving in this direction
that's probably obvious but I want to
make sure that was clear so now we're
still looking down here is Mr
sanderson's back here's his head
here's one arm
here's another arm
here's one leg the other leg now
remember Mr Ramon says that his skis are
in a V
spread eagle so now
if that were to happen then
he stops very quickly and Miss Paltrow
is going to remain at in contact
somewhere around here and her skis
are going to stay underneath Mr
Sanderson
when that happens it's like the center
of mass continuing to move forward while
the skis slow rapidly
which creates an upward Force at that
heel it's going to create a heel release
but as you heard in the testimony all
the skis were on it doesn't work it
takes actually very little Force for
this to release the heel piece to
release in a scenario like this so it
doesn't match with physics and it's the
same way whether one ski or both skis
are in between okay so how do you know
this especially about the bindings
releasing
how are you confident about that my
experience I mean I've seen tons of
binding releases I know how bindings
work
it's uh it's just physics right and
you've specifically done research on
binding releasing oh yes yes and and uh
you said earlier that there were other
scenarios the skis maybe between Mr
Sanderson skis maybe they're diagonal
did you do evaluation of all those sort
of scenarios and did any of those work
no I couldn't get any of them to work so
um the the key is either she would come
out of the bindings or she would be
stuck on Mr Sanderson she wouldn't be
able to move past him if her ski stayed
on in various versions of this I don't
know how she continues to move downhill
the 10 feet that Mr Ramon said she wound
up if her skis are trapped underneath
him and would you expect her to get an
injury in any of these scenarios well
certainly there's that potential yes a
lower extremity injury for sure if for
example her legs get stuck in one of the
scenarios you mentioned right so for
example if her ski is rotated out to the
side going in that V with one of his
skis the other whether it's on the
outside or in the inside can't wind up
well so if her ski is on the outside his
ski is going to push her ski out
um if this is her ski
as he's as he's falling and moving into
that V configuration it's going to
go from this position
to here and it's going to push
her ski outward which I would expect
would create a toe release a twisting
release of the bindings because it
actually takes about 18 pounds of force
between 15 and 20 depending on how her
bindings would be set so very little
Force to release that toe piece but even
if it didn't release then her ski winds
up getting trapped by his and she can't
move for forward so and in many of these
scenarios her leg would get twisted in a
really odd way that would likely create
injuries okay great I think you can sit
down again and now what I'd like to do
is
ask you about
whether you were involved in creating
any animations that would help the jury
understand your opinions in this case
yes and your honor if I may ask for
permission to show the witness these
animations so that I can lay some
Foundation he can use them
yeah we reserve our same objections on
these animations your honor understood
why don't we take a recess while they
straighten out the technology and then
we'll be back
you can step down whatever you need to
do thank you
everything working now yeah sorry that
we had plugged it in before somehow
okay
I'm actually sure is using the thing
all right
why don't you go ahead and have the jury
come in
questions
Dr Cher you can take the stand
we're just waiting for the jury
yes yeah she's monitoring the audio Yeah
foreign
thank you Mr Egan you may proceed yes
yes thank you your honor may I approach
to show the way in this animation
so this animation is number five correct
it is called close up
and I'm gonna play it for you
is this one of the animations that you
helped prepare oh sorry counselor
sure which number is it
number five
it's called close-up
and
22 seconds
so again Mr shirt uh Dr sure you're
um
uh maybe explain to the jury your
involvement in creating this animation
sure I worked with Brian Brill at
Mountain graphics on the uh impact and
fall portion of this animation it's not
meant to represent exactly what happened
but generally the idea of one of the
family of ways this could happen in Miss
Paltrow's version we don't know some of
the exact details of how they contacted
how long they interacted but it gives an
illustration of what it what I'm
thinking my understanding of
her version where they contact she's
contacted from behind and then fall to
the right
and does the animation make certain
assumptions about
various facts and testimony in the
record in this case
yes it does okay and you can explain
those to the jury as we go through it
sure yeah and the animation will help
you explain what you said earlier about
biomechanics applying biomechanics to
this case right exactly okay some
permission to publish this to the jury
your honor
um just we assert our ongoing objection
to the animations or cartoons they uh
black Foundation uh distort the reality
and our incomplete
so animation number five is received for
demonstrative purposes only to help this
witness uh explain his testimony thank
you your honor
so Dr sure I'm gonna
let you
take the reins here and use it as you
need to explain okay I think you're all
right
we also object to the extent that this
witness hasn't testified to any of the
placement of any of the other skiers or
or bodies in this animation
Mr Egan is that relevant to this
witness's testimony of the other skiers
no he's going to talk about the
Collision itself so you should ignore
any of the other skiers that are shown
in the animation
okay so you can reverse it Dr sure to
just uh before the Collision so you can
we can focus on that and explain
what you mean
um to show by this animation maybe I
can't how do you
you could press play again and it will
get to
okay great
so
take us through
um if you would Dr sure what uh
um this animation shows from your point
of view as a biomechanics expert sure
um the first thing that you should be
aware of is that this is Miss Paltrow's
version of the events so Dr sure sorry
to interrupt you just maybe pull your
mind sorry sorry about that the first
thing to be aware of is this is Miss
Paltrow's version of the events so
that's what we're showing here and as we
move forward I'll talk about the physics
kind of like what I drew earlier with
the center of mass and the rotation and
that's the idea that's what went into
this but again this is not exactly what
happened this is just one of the
possible ways it could have happened
so
um
we have Miss Paltrow in Black Mr
Sanderson and the blue
as they move forward in time
it's her testimony that
his skis slid between hers
there we go she felt a contact directly
in the back along her back it sounded
like her buttocks as well
um
it the person was grunting pressing
against her but they were on their skis
for a period of time
if in this situation he's also moving to
skiers right which is in the left in
this image that will create remember I
had the force that was offset from the
center of mass that's going to create a
rightward motion for her but also create
some initial rotation now in in this
portion there's a number of
possibilities she could be adding weight
to her right ski because of the contact
from Mr Sanderson when you ski if you're
in let's just take a snow plow or what
my kids call Pizza position if you wait
the right ski you turn left so if she
waits the the right ski here more
because of the contact she's going to
turn counterclockwise
the contact from Mr Sanderson if it's
more to the right will turn her
counterclockwise so as they're moving to
the right here there would be some
counterclockwise rotation and
here her ski can catch or she could
pitch to the side or they could both
pitch to the side they could both lose
balance we're not sure what happens but
as they're rotating they're continuing
to fall and Miss Sanderson Miss
Paltrow's version has them spooning
essentially as they're coming down
together which would make sense if their
legs got caught up if he was contacting
her below her Center of mass where his
right leg was contacting her right leg
her thigh in that area also consistent
with Miss Paltrow saying that her knee
her right knee was splayed open at the
end and she felt right knee discomfort
that that all could happen there
so as she's rotating and he's rotating
counterclockwise they fall to the side
now
at this point here in the animation
I guess maybe the next frame
if I can do it
Mr Sanderson lands on his right side
maybe the right back it's hard hard to
say if he lands on his right side kind
of like Dr bam said you know he needs to
land on the elbow that can happen that
can create lateral rib fractures
but that's not the only way his arm
could be out he could land on the side
and create lateral rib fractures he can
land on his side and a little bit
towards the back and Miss Paltrow could
land on him she could be fully on him
maybe
um with her her buttocks or her back or
some portion of her Mass compresses his
chest front to back and that can create
his rib fractures there's a lot of
different ways this could happen I can't
tell which one of those is right
but all of those are consistent with her
version of the events
as they hit the snow they would continue
to move forward until friction slows
them down
and it's also important to note we
haven't talked about the head injury but
hitting the back of the head or the side
of the head he could have his head
turned all of those are possibilities
for him to contact his head on the snow
so that's not inconsistent as well
would it be helpful to show it in real
time you've been doing it kind of slow
motion which has been also been very
helpful
maybe maybe start from this beginning
and just play it
objection lacks foundation for
trajectory speed and direction
overruled it's a demonstrative of this
witness's testimony only all right thank
you
okay this is sorry yeah go ahead doctor
this is from the the beginning and if
there's anything you want to comment on
as it happens feel free
I think that accurately reflects the
version that Miss Paltrow testified to
that matches the laws of physics and
biomechanics as I understand them and
would it be helpful to show there's one
other animation that has a little zoom
in from the other angle would that also
be helpful I think yeah I can't hurt
let's show that then permission to
approach your honor for that
what's the number of this animation
this will be number
four it's called zoomed inside
what was the last one James number five
oh that's right
yeah thanks
okay wait just a second
okay Dr sure so I'm playing you number
four the zoomed in from the side version
were you a part of
creating this version as well yes this
is the same animation but from a
different camera view
will this animation also help you
explain the same things you've been
going over with the jury it's the same
thing sure yeah I think it also
visualizes it illustrates my opinion
okay
your honor permission to show this uh
animation subject to the same objections
by the plaintiffs the animation four
zoomed inside is received for
demonstrative purposes only four
doctor sure maybe since we've already
gone through this this slow motion let's
just play this one from the start and
then you can add anything that you can
provide to the jury from this angle sure
here let's play first and then there we
go
I'll wait until the contact point
it's coming up here we go
there's contact
fall to the right
this one doesn't show the rotation quite
as much and we don't know the amount of
counterclockwise rotation as well there
could be a little there could be more or
less right we're not sure but if you if
you go backwards a little bit uh in into
the moment of the Collision
this one maybe
shows does this one show the skis coming
between the skis
yes it does
and I think it's better visualized in
this one yeah and and again what's the
significance of that in terms of how
that mechanism of the Fall occurs
well that's Miss Paltrow's testimony and
it works for the physics of them falling
and rotating slightly counterclockwise
frankly if it wasn't both skis if it was
one ski between hers the kinematics
would be the same for example if his
right ski were on the outside of her
right ski it wouldn't change the general
kinematics this is generally and I keep
saying generally because we don't know
the exact
details of it
this would work
so if we flipped the the positions of
the parties and Mr Sanderson was in
front Miss Paltrow came from behind
using this as a good visual for the jury
we explain that your opinions about what
we would expect to happen
on Mr Ramon's account I should say Well
Mr Ramon's account is very different
because in Mr Ramon's account Mr
Sanderson goes spread eagle and his skis
go out into that V and the inside edges
catch and that changes the kinematics
the motion it's a very different version
of what happens with the contact
and
in terms
I guess we've covered that so maybe
we'll wrap up here the
um
you've covered a lot of things a lot of
new things perhaps for members of the
jury and those of us in the room will
you um
will you
summarize for us
um what is what are the main points you
want to get across for the jury here
sure the first is that Dr babe cannot
say with any accuracy that Miss Paltrow
landed on Mr Sanderson his calculations
are wrong and when you look at the
equations done properly
Mr Sanderson can land on the snow and
sustain his injuries without Miss
Paltrow falling on him
sure was it your understanding that Dr
Bam's opinion was that his account was
the only possible way the injuries could
occur yes Mr Ramon's version was the
only possible way he said Miss paltrows
was impossible which I believe is false
I think Miss Paltrow's version is
possible
right and would you say that miss
pauchos is the more likely of the two
accounts well considering it's the only
one that matches with the physics of
what would happen in contact yes I think
so okay and I interrupted you you were
going through your main points what was
the next one well I think we've covered
it the second thing is that Dr bam
cannot say that Miss Paltrow's version
is impossible that's absolutely wrong it
sounds like you're saying in contrast to
Dr Bain that there are various ways this
accident could have happened the
injuries could have
occurred for Mr Sanderson is that right
that's correct and
um you've evaluated the various
testimony correct I have any you've done
a careful analysis from a biomechanical
engineer's perspective on what different
scenarios might be likely or how they
would happen correct correct and and is
it your opinion that Miss Pancho's
version is the more likely of the two
versions that you looked at Mr Ramones
and Miss Paltrow yes once again it's the
only version out of the two that matches
with the laws of physics the the
biomechanics of it okay
anything else you'd like to tell the
jury that maybe I I interrupted you on
and you you missed out on
yeah I think we're we're good okay thank
you that's all for now in your honor
screen there sure you can turn it off
well actually leave it on for right now
on or off okay
do you prefer doctor sure sure that
works sure doctor sure
um
this version right here
back it up about to here on the scroll
to here yeah and then go forward it out
halfway between the last one
a little farther
just before when we when uh
Mr Sanderson who's also uh maybe it's
easier if you did well could you just go
a little bit farther forward just go
slow I just want to get Mr Sanderson who
sometimes called Dr Sanderson Mr here
would you mind putting on the remote
that allows you to be picked up
okay oh wait now it is
okay go a little farther forward please
okay and then when we get okay now this
is uh
Terry Sanderson
that's Mr Sanderson that's right okay
so his right eye is
okay go a little farther
you know
fractions
so
you have a you have his head turned
that's based on your testimony that uh
he is looking
down the hill I guess is that what
you're saying uh I believe his testimony
is that he's looking at a woman who's a
little downhill to the left
he notices her looks at her I don't
remember what the exact words are okay
go a little farther
so his head his
his left eye would be looking drag Dave
Miss Paltrow he was here right
I believe so he and uh it's inconsistent
with his testimony he didn't see her at
all that's correct
wouldn't he I would think so
farther just another fraction
okay
now in this picture you don't have
doctor or excuse me Craig Ramon in there
um
how far above
would
this point be
where I just pointed pointed at 20 yards
without the above
image right here I I don't know without
doing a measurement but I'm
concentrating on the collision between
Mr Sanderson and Miss Paltrow
well Craig Ramon testifies he was about
30 to 40 feet above
so these objects are about five you know
been over maybe five feet high
you know six bodies we'd get to 30 feet
that would be about right here
I'm not sure
well you're an engineer highly trained
PhD you can't even guesstimate that uh
that would be about 30 feet
I I can't tell
what uh up here be 30 feet
oh you think it'd be a lot more than 30
feet
probably but I don't know
will you help create this animation
you don't know the distances in your own
animation
you know I've concentrated on the
Collision portion that's the
biomechanics portion
okay who who did the uh as the estimates
or guesstimates of the distances of the
bodies of the other people so that's
going to be uh Mr boggard who's going to
be on soon I assume
Okay so
uh this animation doesn't have Craig
Ramon in in the scene at all not at this
point
okay
is it because the defense doesn't want
him in the scene
so to discredit his witness account
oh I don't think that's the case at all
and you'll have to ask Mr Bogart
okay
we will
okay let's see just go another little
section
you just tell me when I'll keep going
and yeah just go slow I just want to go
slow motion
okay now stop right there
now do you know the top how much time
from the initial let's say impact of
their bodies to this point would be you
did this calculation this is your your
bail awake you're what you're talking
about
do you mean in the animation or do you
mean in real I know
Yeah Yeah from the impact at this point
approximately
a fourth of a second a half a second
tenth of a second do you miss Paltrow
says that they're in contact for a
little while a few seconds before they
fall over so I I don't know what it is
in particular in this animation
if that's what you're asking so you
helped design this part of the animation
so you don't know how far
it is you just guessed it
again we don't know exact timing and
distance this represents an illustration
of the version so
um
yeah it is what it is it's an
illustrator an illustration of the
version but there could be wide
variability in that version right there
is variability but we have constraints
on it
the constraints are it could have
happened the opposite way right
the opposite way so miss Paltrow hit
Terry Sanderson no I don't think so not
with the testimony that's given we have
two versions We have Mr Ramon's version
and we have missed Miss Paltrow's
version this is Miss Paltrow's version
Mr Ramon's version is very different
okay let's talk about that for a second
um
come on
you're being paid excuse me you're being
paid
what is it 425 an hour for this no is it
more than 425 an hour it is
um 450 an hour 500 it's 500 an hour 500
an hour
and uh you build something over ten
thousand dollars so far for your work
that sounds about right
more than fifteen thousand no I don't
think so so between ten and fifteen
thousand
okay
uh you can turn that off for right now
I think that's probably
better okay
what's the best way to do it is
disconnected
okay
no you're here to teach the uh the jury
right the defendants version correct uh
teach the jury the physics that would be
helpful in understanding how to assess
the accident
so that's a no you're not teaching the
defendant's version
I'm not teaching any version I'm
teaching the physics and mechanical
engineering biomechanical engineering
that would help the jury I know it's
hard for expert witnesses to say yes or
no but
are you teaching the defendant's version
I guess I don't understand the question
okay
seemed like a simple question
next I'd like to uh
talk about did you review Dr Gibby's
testimony at trial uh no but I did see
some of his trial testimony
all of it are some of it some of it
was it more than 10 minutes
probably yeah more than 20 minutes
yep more than an hour I don't think more
than an hour
you didn't disclose anything about
hearing Dr Gibby's testimony
um
not sure what you mean but I did see it
okay
um
you've never disclosed to the plaintiff
your reports or your testimony ahead of
this trial correct
um may we approach
yes
foreign
are you an expert on broken ribs
I am comfortable talking about the
biomechanics related to rip fractures
have you done any papers or studies or
research on
ribs and rib fractures me personally no
but I've read the biomechanical and
Engineering literature relevant to them
okay
you haven't mentioned that biomechanical
literature
specifics correct
I'm not sure about in specifics but I
think we mentioned it on direct
okay
so you said that uh
Dr Sanderson I'm just going to call him
Terry Terry was 70 years old at the time
of this crash it was 69 but
effectively 70 for biomechanics purposes
effectively because 70 years older
no because there's actually good
information in the biomechanical
engineering literature about the amount
of chest compression required to create
rib fractures for 70 year olds
and not 69 year olds well it's actually
the full distribution but the paper that
I'm thinking of from Agnew specifically
talks about 70 year olds
you didn't mention that paper today no
but you would you like it not right now
thanks
I've not seen it
um
let's see
I'm going to go right to the another
point
you have this theory of rotation correct
that your the version you're calling
Miss Paltrow's version is a kind of a
rotation version
there is some rotation it may be a
little it might be more than a little we
don't know
okay so we don't know how much rotation
there is
correct sure okay
I'd like to
let me see what this thing is it didn't
work last time
maybe we take a picture of this I think
you've already done it for someone on
your team ask okay good
you may borrow a pen
your honor we would object to him
writing on the witnesses board
it's not an exhibit he's it's certainly
fair game okay
so well doctor can we mark it as an
exhibit your honor why don't you take a
picture of it and you can use that and
then he can he can add to it okay
it is our board
right in in academically we don't we
don't have any questions right now so in
academic Fields it's common that people
write on each other's uh drawings
correct
I don't know that I've seen that but I
don't have a problem with you drawing
okay
so um
you testified that Craig Ramon says
Terry was hit directly in the back
and they went down and Craig Ramon was
somewhere above 30 to 40 feet
and it happened in a fraction of a
second correct
yes the fall I would agree with that
okay less than a second
sure okay
so uh there was a screen
so with and the screen occurred and
there was within a fraction of a second
and uh
I don't believe uh Craig Ramon never
testified where Miss Paltrow's skis were
correct so her skis could have been
going underneath Terry
like this
so the pink ones are would be Miss
Paltrow skis is that a version that is
possible it is none
it's a
uh
you're saying it's not possible that is
not possible with the version that Mr
Ramon States
his version
didn't talk about her skis now here I'll
draw what her body let's pink would be
her body still Square in the back
isn't that possible
so no with Mr Ramon's version if I may
um that is not possible so in this
situation here when Mr sanderson's skis
go into a V and I guess you're saying
her skis are under his skis which I'm
not sure how that happens because the
tips curve up but we'll go with it
somehow
she winds up in this situation getting
caught with her left ski around Mr
Sanderson and she would not continue
past five to ten feet and I would expect
a twisting release of her left ski well
that's her version I'm talking about Mr
Ramon's version no no I'm talking about
what you just drew from Mr Ramon's
version Mr Ramon's well isn't it
possible her skis could be pointing
straight like this
and uh let me get it right here
so
yeah so
she could be going straight and she
could be turning left
and up
and hit Square in the back but and her
skis are pointed this way isn't that
another version
so for her skis to miss oh no it's not
do you want me to explain
after a second I want
I'm asking the questions here here so
the uh
so are you saying that her body could
not be turned well her skis are going in
one direction or she's turning up to the
left is that is that possible not for Mr
Ramon's version is it possible in
general sure but in her version I'm
sorry in his version this happened in a
fraction of a second
I don't think Mr Ramon testified that he
has a videographic or photographic
memory
do you
well he's pretty particular in his
testimony about how she was on Mr
sanderson's back
right and he could
you see the circle I have
let's see well actually um
maybe I could do it I've got it wrong
let's do it the other way
hurt
her body to be like this
and her skis could be like this too
and
people turn all the time while they're
skiing and their skis are going One
Direction but their body is pointing at
a different direction here can you see
me
you see that I see you turning sure
that's possible Right
what you're doing in general is possible
are you asking does that match with Mr
Ramon's testimony no I'm happy to
explain why I think Mr Ramon's
testimonies
it happens in a fraction of a second Mr
Ramon
professional wannabe freestyle skier
likes to talk about ski angles but the
main part is the body you saw the body
and then the bodies go down together and
she lands on top of him
you're saying that your versions which
you are not based on anything
except
your Recreation of the biomechanics are
superior to an eyewitness is that what
you're saying no we have two versions of
the accident we have Mr Ramon's version
and we have Miss Paltrow's version I
have assessed both using physics and
biomechanics and I'm sorry to say Mr
Ramon's version does not meet with the
laws of physics it's not consistent
internally consistent and paltrows is
well I don't think Mr Ramon's version
was designed to be consistent with the
version of events it happened in less
than a second and we don't know the
direction of the skis
in his version he never testified to the
direction of his Paltrow's skis in any
of his testimony isn't that true
he did not testify to the direction of
her schemes that's true thank you so if
Miss Paltrow
was seen Down
turning up to the left
she hits the Terry Sanderson Square in
the back
and they go they can fall down to the
right
especially if her momentum
is going well you know I'm not a
biomechanical engineer I'll try to do it
right here
it could be your shoulder that had some
Square in the back
he didn't say what a part of this
Paltrow's body
Mr Sanderson did he he did not say he
said well here I can tell you what
exactly what he said he said
he said squarely in the back
she couldn't have hit him in the back
any better right in the middle than if
she tried and she couldn't have been
back on his back anymore than if he
would have strapped her on the back like
a backpack
okay but that doesn't mean her body was
straight
might not be exactly straight
yeah it could be off center because she
was
skiing down she's like this and she hits
him right in the back
or maybe it was a little off center
because Mr Ramon only had the view for a
few seconds
and then
her arms wrap around
your arms could have wrapped around
Terry Sanderson right
I don't think there's any testimony
about that is it possible maybe but well
where would they have gone
down to the side she went in like this
um
in front of her
um I mean the most likely don't ski or
ski like this usually
often often what are the other positions
they can have her arms in more okay
let's have them out more so she could be
like this down like this and the holes
heading back okay there's all sorts of
options
so in that fraction of a second Mr Ramon
saw the Collision the screen was up here
he turns his head
and she could hit him squaring the back
she could have her but at that point her
body could have turned and possibly hit
her but the point is the skis could have
been going at a different angle
one or the other
and still caused this crash and your
versions assume those are not possible
because
you uh assume that
that there's only one way that their
skis were going parallel to each other
this is the only this is your only
assumption right wrong
you assume you made assumptions that
these are possible I looked at other
angles that's right
and the testimony though
you said uh
there's no testimony about the angle of
her Skies from Mr Ramon correct that's
true
you've made a lot of assumptions correct
to make these animations right
um
yes and no
I thought that would be a
more than one assumption
there are some assumptions
sure more than one assumption okay
less than a hundred
sure
less than 10.
I don't know you don't know how many
assumptions you've made correct
that's right sure okay
I know Council
Mr Owens likes to do this a lot like
it's a touchdown
but
on redirect Mr Ramon did you see all of
his testimony this for this trial
I don't know if I saw all of it but
certainly I saw a lot of it
okay you saw the testimony last week
correct
is there any more than that there was a
little bit yesterday okay I didn't see
anything yesterday traveling had to do
with that he reported Mr Ramon reported
what he he saw
the same day in the same week seven
years ago
and you're recreating this what about
five months ago correct
I remember when it was less than a year
ago
I don't recall you don't recall when you
made your consulted with Mr Brill and
made the animation this has been ongoing
for a while this case has been dragging
on so I don't know when it was
so you've been working on this for let's
say more than eight months
sure you don't know
um certainly we've been in contact with
uh Council for longer than eight months
but for the record your honor I'd like
to move to strike all of his testimony
because
this wasn't disclosed improperly
I I anticipate the rules I just wanted
for the record make them it's overruled
it was disclosed properly Council okay
what I'd like to do is uh
understand that you've made a lot of
assumptions and the jury would like to
know how reliable your opinions are so
how can that be reliable when you
totally discount some major events like
what the direction of Miss Paltrow's
body was compared to her skis and there
is testimony about
Miss Paltrow's
body movement
um
do you know that
just prior to the crash what version are
you talking about I don't know what
you're talking about sorry do you know
about the version of Carrie Oaks
I don't think she saw the accident
have you read her deposition I have
hey you realize she testified that
one of the kids said Mommy watch us ski
and the kids were up there on the left
Miss Paltrow was down on the right which
would tend to show that
Miss Paltrow was looking up to her left
at the point of collision
I don't recall that okay
so Yuri you're excluding Carrie oaks's
testimony correct that's wrong
you're including her testimony I
considered it sure
and you
are there any assumptions you've made
based on her testimony
not in particular that I can think of
but there may be could you speak up not
in particular that I can think of okay
not particularly that you can think of
about Carrie oaks's testimony okay
are you an expert on head injuries
I'm comfortable talking about head
injuries from the biomechanics
standpoint have you ever studied
or held yourself out as an expert on
concussion
if it's diagnosing or treating
concussion no if it's the biomechanics
related to the formation of concussion
yes I've done helmet research and head
injury research in particular for snow
Sports
did you apply any of your knowledge
about concussion to this case
I certainly looked at it but Dr Bain was
very particular in his testimony that it
was only the rib fractures that allowed
him to say that Miss Paltrow contacted
Mr Sanderson from behind so that's what
I concentrated on for the jury
and you ignored his discussion about the
head injury oh no I certainly considered
it
and it's not relevant in this case well
in disproving Dr bam it's not relevant
but I'm happy to talk about it
well it's not clear you disproved Dr
bang when you don't even know the
direction of Miss Paltrow's skis
at the beginning of this it's also
I think a big assumption to say what the
body position of Miss Paltrow was when
she hit
Terry Sanderson in the back
metal was there a question in there
Council just if that was accurate I'll
withdraw it
so you've never studied rib injuries
have you ever testified about rib
injuries before
the question is have you ever studied
rib injuries and
testified about them in the past
that's like two questions have you ever
testified about rib injuries in the past
I I don't recall but it's likely
most likely you have I think so how many
have you testified more than 100 times
in trial probably 35 times something in
that ballpark
in total under oath have you testified
more than 100 times including
depositions yes
more than less than 200 times I would
agree with that
okay
let me just check
that's all I have for now thank you Dr
sure thank you thank you Mr Bueller Mr
Egan
thank you your honor Dr sure we'll just
be real quick here
did anything Mr Bueller asked you change
your opinion that Miss Paltrow's account
is consistent with the laws of physics
to your understanding and Mr Ramones is
not
That Remains the Same
thanks
Mr Bueller
you said this before you're an expert in
the laws of physics but you're not an
expert in
Medical
uh
medicine or Orthopedics
or neurology correct
I am a biomechanical engineer I am not a
medical doctor I do not diagnose and
treat but I do look at what forces and
what motions create damage to the body
you may step down thank you thank you
may call your next Witness
we call Paul bonger your honor thank you
or before Mr Bogger
fight we may want to take a five or ten
minute break I want to address something
with
the jury we'll have to take one shortly
anyway so let's go ahead and do it now
miss van Orman
your honor pursuant to our motion and
limiting Mr bogger's testimony is going
to be significantly Limited in this case
um the problem that I am foreseeing is
that
um I and I could be wrong but it appears
to me that council is going to try and
use Mr Bogger to then
um
describe some further animations and
place individuals on that animation and
I have significant concerns with that
for a number of reasons number one Mr
bogger's not qualified to do that he
didn't take any kind of measurements
calculations determinations of speed
force physics Etc in this case but in
addition in his report he does not make
any mention of where people were where
they were placed this would any kind of
discussion of him talking about the
animation and if he was responsible for
putting the people somehow on that
animation he does not describe that in
his report he doesn't talk that in his
report regarding
participating in an animation he
provides you know diagrams in his report
no discussions of where people were or
weren't so I don't think that it would
be appropriate for him to even deal with
the animation or that his testimony that
he's the one that was responsible for
putting say apple here and Moses here
here and that type of thing that would
go significantly beyond anything he did
in his report
so that's my concern I wanted to address
that now rather than a sidebar
thank you
sure
Mr Egan
yes you're on Earth so I think our
response would be that
um Mr Bogger has
poured over the records in this case and
he has in producing these animations
made certain assumptions about which
what testimony
might be consistent with the
illustration that the animations provide
he can be very clear with the jury that
he's assuming certain facts he's not
finding these facts he's assuming that
they are true they come from the record
he can explain that they're they're
rough illustrations he's not made
measurements and decided that yes this
is exactly 30 feet I mean he can be
subject to cross-examination on
um on any point that might be
inconsistent with testimony he can
explain that he chose to assume these
facts and not other facts and if you
assumed other facts you might get
different illustration
and then he you know he'll explain that
the Assumption of various facts that are
shown in the
animations are consistent with his
understanding of ski collisions and ski
skiing skiing generally which he has
Decades of experience not just with
skiing himself but with investigating
accidents collisions hundreds and
hundreds of them for various purposes
mostly not litigation mostly to figure
out risk management concerns deciding
whether certain skiers have to be banned
from a certain Resort or a ski area
he's he has
ample experience to be able to discuss
how to
consider various factors in
evaluating a ski Collision like this
that has complex
testimony that's not all consistent and
the jury in our in our view needs to
hear from a ski expert that knows how to
do that and can explain to them the
principles that he uses he will not tell
the jury this is likely what happened or
that I have found that this has this
must be the case he'll say I've assumed
these facts can be very clear about what
he's assumed and then use that animation
to explain to the jury How to Think
Through the case given his ample
experience with evaluating ski
collisions
so Mr Egan I guess I'm still not hearing
an expert opinion for Mr Bogger is it
that uh that would have helped the jury
I mean everything that I'm hearing has
him weighing evidence has him making
decisions about what may have happened
on that day and that's invading the
prominence of the jury it's not really
going to help them
your honor I see it as uh like say in
medical malpractice case which I'm more
familiar with if a certain set of facts
might be in the record about what
happened in a surgery for example than a
surgeon expert surgeon who has lots of
experience reviewing and records of also
doing the surgery himself knowing what
the training is
looks at the records looks at the
various claims and and you as you said
in your order ruling I believe yesterday
can say I if we assume these facts given
my expertise I can say this makes sense
or this is consistent with my
understanding of surgery
um and so
my proposal is that we use Mr bocker in
that sort of way where he can help the
jury understand given what he knows
about skiing and given what he's seen in
the record that there are certain
principles you can use if you assume
certain facts to
um
to evaluate a certain Collision such
that you you're applying some rational
principles rather than just generally
going with a certain Gestalt feeling
about what someone said you're actually
trying to rationally go through how to
evaluate a ski Collision which again he
has decades and Decades of experience
doing and he won't say he'll say to the
jury you're
the ones that have to decide what
happened this is a very difficult case
to decide
your medical malpractice expert example
isn't that an expert that's coming in to
evaluate
whether the standard of care was
breached
yeah well so yes usually we would we
would offer an expert in that way but
given your ruling I'm just trying to use
that as an analogy where we could still
use expertise that would help the jury
without rendering that that final
opinion telling them you know as an
expert I you know you should you should
do this and I'm really the one that
knows because I have tons of experience
instead he can say here's here's how I
evaluate these accidents and let me show
you how to do it and then they have they
have rational principles that come from
his field of skiing and ski accident
evaluation that that help them that they
have not heard they haven't heard from
any ski expert that has provided to them
that kind of a rational
layout for analyzing the various complex
claims in this case and I think that
would help them sure and I think I in my
I guess preliminary ruling on this
witness the other day yesterday yeah I'm
losing track of the day is here I think
I stated that he is qualified certainly
has qualifications and can testify as to
what a reasonable skier would do or not
do in a certain hypothetical set of
facts but in terms of applying and
weighing the evidence in this case I
think that goes too far
okay so but but if if we showed the
animation and we made it clear to the
jury that we're assuming certain facts
were not we're not weighing them we're
just saying look let's let's take these
facts we're assuming them we're not
saying that they're proven we're just
showing you how to analyze the facts
assuming these uh these various parts of
the testimony are true that would be too
far you're saying that sounds like
closing argument
it doesn't sound like what a witness can
offer under rule 702
I mean he's an expert in skiing he can
talk about skiing Dynamics he can
explain what a snow plow is what
parallel skiing is what uh what the
rules of of skiing are generally
understood to be but in terms of taking
that next leap
I don't I don't think he can he can say
I've looked at the deposition testimony
and I can tell you who's at fault here
or I can tell you who did something
wrong here
I just don't see I think that's the
jury's responsibility and I don't want a
witness telling the jury how to make its
decisions or how to think how to how to
make a decision that's either an
ultimate issue or one of the issues
leading up to that ultimate issue
so even him explaining his process for
how to evaluate ski collisions would be
too far
to what end
what is the jury need to know how he
evaluates a ski Collision because
evaluating his key collisions is a
complex matter and he has expertise as
to how to do that yeah
you know right now I'm just talking in a
or I'm responding to your question sort
of in a vacuum I don't know what it is
he's offering
if it would help I could give you kind
of an example like sure if I could say
you Mr Bogger when you evaluate ski
collisions and you've evaluated they
have established that he's evaluated
hundreds of and hundreds of ski
collisions
um have you ever evaluated collisions
where there's conflicting testimony yes
when you approach that testimony what
are principles you use to evaluate that
and he can explain those principles he
doesn't have to talk about the facts of
this case he can explain here are these
principles I don't think the juries
heard that I think it would be helpful
to them I think it would be rational and
not over it wouldn't be overbearing
asking him how he evaluates
credibility
um
I guess that's true how does he
reconcile different accounts right but
we wouldn't if I mean if given your
ruling we we wouldn't go into applying
it to this case we would just give them
the rational principles that would help
them weigh the evidence it wouldn't tell
them how to do it it would just give
them a framework for doing it which only
he can provide may have not heard from
somebody that has that does this for a
living has done it again how does that
vary from what the jury does
if you look at the credibility and jury
instruction that I've already read for
example and how does that differ mean
where it talks about conflicting
testimony how does it how does what he's
offering provide any specialized
knowledge I consider that generalization
yeah so I don't think he would just talk
about you know
um general principles of evaluating
Witnesses he would talk about particular
aspects of a ski ski slope or Witnesses
on us
um
if you were here right now he could help
me
um
um yeah right he is right here so when
when ski accidents happen uh
and people go to the ground their their
skis get released
I could see that as specialized
knowledge just like this witness offered
something along those lines no that
isn't that that is an important thing he
can but in terms of
this skier said such and such and this
gear said such and such but this is what
I this is how I evaluate that aspect of
it I think that's invading the
Providence of the jury
okay on deciding how to weigh a
testimony okay I mean for the record if
if I may your honor would just I think
we put this on before but in case we
didn't we we believe the motion uh to
exclude Dr Bogger or limit his testimony
is untimely and that um Greg scored us
their expert who whose report does much
the same thing that Mr bocker's report
does should be limited in the same way
um
and again just renew our requests that
he'd be able to speak to the jury about
his evaluation the ski accident
so just again Mike my sort of ultimate
conclusion on what I'm hearing from on
this motion to reconsider and on the
response from the defense is that it's
up to the jury to decide ultimately what
the parties did
where the parties were positioned and
who ran into whom
so it's up for the jury to make those
decisions so as long as this witness
tears clear of those areas that's the
main emphasis of my of my preliminary
ruling and I'll have to hear what is
what's being offered do you mind uh I
know I'm not an old man but my memory
has failed me this three again who hit
whom going backwards Missouri to decide
ultimately what the parties did right in
other words leading up to during and
after the accident it's up for the jury
to decide that
um where the and various experts have
given them
some helpful information like the uh the
the biomedical expert gave testimony as
to what the biomedical evidence
reflected that would help the jury make
that decision just like this past
witness gave the jury some
biomechanical information that will help
the jury make their decision about what
happened in that accident what the
parties did where the parties were
positioned and who ran into whom
and and the reason that you see Mr
bhagar as doing something different than
like say doctor sure just did who took
the jury through a assuming these
various facts I'm not telling you that
this account is true
and I'm just taking their the as an
assumption what Ms Paltrow said was true
let's analyze it you're seeing Mr bongar
as different and I'm not totally sure
how do you mind explaining that
plaintiff's witness
applied biomedical principles in a
methodical way to the different versions
and then handed the jury that
information the biomechanical expert
that just testified
applied biomechanical principles to the
different versions and gave that
information to the jury to help them
make a decision okay so and what I what
I see this witness doing is reading
different accounts and reconciling them
and wanting to give that his his
reconciliation to the jury which I think
is too close to what the jury actually
does it doesn't provide any it doesn't
help the jury from an expert standpoint
okay so it sounds like you're not
persuaded that you know of our position
which is that he has skiing expertise
similar to like a biomechanical engineer
has and can apply that to the facts in a
way that would provide the jury with
some again rational
scheme to assess the the accident that
they wouldn't have otherwise rule 702
and and the same would like is likely
going to hold true to Mr scordus's
testimony
I haven't I mean I've heard I've heard
you make kind of emotion I haven't heard
from the other side whether they're
opposing that in some way you just wait
until you have questions I mean if he's
the same type of an expert and I I
realize that he may not be a risk
manager and he may not
be a ski accident investigator for for
an employer but it sounds like his
testimony is along the same lines
so
um just in terms of guidance on this
ruling
um
you you mentioned the bindings and I
apologize if we're going along I just
want to make sure that we
um
specialized knowledge right so it can
help the jury in making their decision
so would in your mind would something
like recognizing that the positioning of
the skiers if one skier is uphill
applying a certain knowledge of skiing
um uh that that would suggest certain
things about the accident would that be
out of bounds
I guess I have to hear the question but
it it sounds like you're
getting back into the you know making
conclusions based on an investigation if
you say if you if you lay out some
hypothetical facts to say if this skier
was here and this skier was here from a
skiing standpoint
you know and then ask questions based on
that I could see that but okay
um
it's feeling a little too hypothetical
right now sure okay thank you your honor
thanks for your patience with my my
questions sure miss van Orman
back to why I raised this in the first
place is the concern with the animation
and so what I don't want because Mr
Bogger apparently had some involvement
in in creating the animation which was
not designated in his report nor was any
mention on what his involvement was what
he did for it how he placed anybody
anybody anywhere there's no discussion
of any of that I don't think that it's
appropriate for him to comment on the
animation and to say well yes I I saw
that you know this helps me because I'm
the one who helped to place these people
there it would have been Again by
reading the depositions and applying
which is what the jury needs to do so I
would say he can't even talk about the
animations because that just goes beyond
the scope of his report anything that
he's done in the case
I would agree
unless the foundation can be set I mean
I haven't heard anything that would
establish a foundation
your honor we had a 37-page report
produce a long long time ago there was a
motion deadline that we respected
months ago
that these issues were ordered were
argued 45 days ago
and then immediately before our witness
is going to take the stand with this
37-page report
we get
essentially a midnight filing
and that got half of his opinions I
don't think it's fair your honor I can't
even read the darn thing I'm focused on
getting my Witnesses ready
the untimeliness is very prejudicial to
us your honor because we can't properly
brief this in days
I've already ruled that the that the
initial motion was timely and and I made
a ruling on the initial motion the
subsequent motion was not untimely the
court has agreed to reconsider the
motion and that's what I've done and I
don't feel that it's unfair or unduly
prejudicial you are aware of the issues
with his report long ago but but you
ruled in our favor before what I Ruled
was that the that the initial motion
didn't give the court enough to Grant it
because they
and so that they were the most briefed
it then there was a motion to reconsider
that gave the court more information and
I can see that it would be
I mean you can't poorly breathe this
would create an appealable issue do you
want to do that for your client is my
question
no but I don't I don't wanna
they poorly brief something the judge
denies it
then right before the testimony they
better brief it and now we lose I mean
that's what trial is this is trial
things happen
the the points that were raised in the
motion are valid points they're sound
they're based soundly on the law and I
and I want to make sure that what the
jury hears
is sound and and not subject to any more
risk of appeal than possible
we'll take five before the jury comes
back
thank you
ready for the jury
yes
yes we're right okay
I didn't hear anything so they went to
get the jury
I see that
thank you
Mr Owen G May proceed
again okay Mr Egan we call Paul Bogger
our ski expert thank you Mr Bogger
if you could walk right over here to the
clerk and she will swear you in as a
witness
do you swear that the testimony you're
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
God thank you
good morning
start by sitting down and then giving
the jury your full name and spelling it
to get situated thank you very much
yes my name is Paul Bogger
p-a-u-l-b-a-u-g-h-e-r
unner I note that my computer is still
there do you mind if I grab it sure
Mr Bogger thank you for being with us
thank you
will you tell the jury what you
understand To Be Your Role here today
yes I was retained to do an
investigation to consider all the
circumstances involved in the accident
that you've been sitting through here
and I've also been asked to
if asked to assume certain facts I could
Give opinions as to how that might work
would that be plausible do I see this I
think maybe a lot of what I would hope
to add today would be to
sort of give the operational side the
skiing side the things that we observe
and accidents and when we evaluate them
what we learn and what I pass on I do a
lot of teaching and training which we
can get into but those are I think the
sort of the key the key areas so do you
have expertise to
help educate the jury about this here
responsibility code yes or just
reasonable principles about how to ski
yes
um what about how
like for example
um bindings uh and ski equipment might
factor into how they might work in a
certain Collision
yes
and why do you why do you have uh
confidence that you can explain that and
with authority to the jury
well I've been involved in working
professionally in the ski industry for
37 years and I've primarily focused on
the outdoor on snow
skiing more specifically ski safety that
involves ski accidents I do a lot of ski
accident investigation I mean literally
thousands and thousands and I've done a
lot of collisions I've worked on a lot
of collisions and I haven't just done it
at one skier in my home ski area but
I've I actually had four ski areas that
I did uh risk management oversight for
and and I'm primarily a patrol director
at my base but then I moved into more
supervisory roles that started to
involve other ski areas as well
including one in Canada one here in Utah
that you're probably familiar with
Brighton
and uh
those experiences of looking at these
accidents in a variety of locations has
given me quite a bit of information I
can use to a
do the day-to-day use of that do we need
to address certain issues on the hill do
we need to remove a skier for example if
somebody's unsafe in bad collisions and
bad accidents we really do need to learn
as much as we can we get medical
feedback we get we just consider a lot
of information and then the last piece
of that is I pass a lot of that on I've
been training and teaching
people in the ski industry about
accident investigations skier collisions
gear safety uh for the last 20 years and
so I've been all over on that do you
have any higher education yes I have a
degree in economics
and what about
um
certifications that are related to Ski
Sports or skiing
yes I would have a number of
certifications I'm not sure how many of
them would bear directly on the ski
accident part but uh you know I'm an EMT
an instructor of outdoor Emergency Care
um a licensed Blaster an aerial Blaster
which means we can use explosives from
helicopters and and mostly for Avalanche
control well I guess only for Avalanche
control if there's anything else
probably be a big problem I'm sure my
license doesn't say that but and then I
have a number of uh
schools that have attended Avalanche
schools and various ski risk management
type things and then you know as I said
really the last 20 25 years of my career
I've been mostly teaching and training
others whether it's
a national Avalanche school which we
actually just held here in Utah in the
fall or
Consulting for ski areas working with
the national ski areas Association on
national Safety campaigns the national
ski patrol system was on the national
Safety Board and so there's a lot of
related things but I mean I think that's
the gist that you know I've been
involved in
you know I like to even say as you know
I've been referred to as an expert in
this for a long time and I've done a lot
of Trials and testimony on ski cases but
I always think of myself too as a
student I'm all I'm continually learning
about it I always want to know the next
thing and you think they're all the same
and a lot are fairly similar but there's
always something new and something
different so
have you ever in your
um capacity you mentioned of
reviewing cases for litigation or giving
testimony in court cases have you ever
done that in Utah before yes yes I had a
what was that well I've had a number of
uh secure collisions that I've
investigated here now with Brighton
that's more my oversights and I'm
reviewing the accident
records and then when we have a bigger
Collision that has more issues and so
forth or a ski accident for that matter
you know I'll get involved and I you
know start going through a review like
much like we've been doing here and I
had a trial I think three or four years
ago in Salt Lake uh Solitude the ski
area was involved and
uh Park City I've had a couple of
collisions at Park City that have done
expert reports and and so forth but uh
you know those cases settled but but
anyway so yeah and that's again I think
what's different about what I do than
say maybe what Mr Graf would have been
doing uh when he was the patrol manager
is that I I do travel and I do go to all
the different
parts of the country including the East
Coast for accidents and the
investigations and secure collisions
happen basically everywhere and that's
been a
I'd say I've probably had 20 uh
cases that have gone to trial that I've
been involved in maybe they haven't all
gone to draw but at least that have been
in litigation
and are you aware of any studies or have
you done any measurements of how common
ski accidents might be
well I'm certainly uh I work with people
who who actually are involved in the uh
what we call the 10-year interval
studies and there's been four tenure
interval studies about ski accidents and
the mechanisms of ski accidents I look
at that data I also uh excuse me I think
you heard Dr share earlier describing
the ISS
s uh the the snow Sports
and Trauma uh you know the international
Congress for ski safety on that and I've
presented there I've presented a
I you know I can't probably keep track
of all the different meetings and and
groups that I've presented to but these
are bigger groups the ISS s and then
I've you know I also present papers and
and do peer-reviewed uh uh work the
international snow science conference
issw Workshop has a
that was dreamed up in the 80s they
haven't lost that part of it but it's a
conference it's an International
Conference a thousand people there I do
reports on things that happen ski area
problem ski
in fact one ski problem with the uh snow
immersion suffocation
I don't know if you've heard of that you
might have heard of tree will fatalities
did you remember we just had one
here in in Utah and and so that would be
something I would gather data on I
talked to the general manager of the ski
area that had happened adjacent to and
and talked to the folks from the
Avalanche Center here forecast Center
and they have some educational Outreach
that they do and I basically was at the
uh
front of the snow version piece I helped
coin that term and and we did it you
know I keep a database I keep doing
ongoing research I see you have another
question coming no no it's fine well I
just don't mind me interrupting so the
the when it comes to measuring that how
common a ski collisions might be on in a
given region or in a given place at a
given time do you have any particular
data you can offer yeah well certainly
um if you looked at I mentioned those
interval studies uh the rate in skiing
accidents the total skiing accidents of
collisions is about six to seven percent
of all of the reported accidents now I'm
sure there's a lot of collisions where
people just bump into each other and go
on their way probably a lot more of
those but uh ones that result
fine if this is just
just Brown Foundation on Mr bogger's
experience but this goes beyond anything
contained in his report
you see it as background so overruled
yeah
yes so um that rate at six to seven
percent is sort of uncanny from interval
to intervals of 40 Years of data now and
it's still the same and now I use that
metric myself because I'm looking at the
four skier is that I'm supervising and
then the other ski areas that I go to
when I do investigations I look at their
data because the first thing I want to
know is what is that rate here and it
can vary throughout the season based on
weather conditions and smoke surfaces
and so forth but uh you know that's a
metric is are we doing okay do we have a
problem is there something that needs to
be addressed and so I look at it in all
accidents there's all kinds of data you
can get from accidents not just gear
collisions in that way and then we try
to pass that information on sometimes we
target it towards safety Outreach what
you can look at a lot of safety stuff on
the national ski areas association
website that anybody can log on to and
look at the safety pages and a lot of
the stuff on collisions that's in there
and skiing safely and so forth I had a
lot to offer in the in the production of
all that thank you
um do you have any knowledge of how what
the rate of uh ski collisions
um might be in Utah some in there yes
and it would be almost identical yeah
there might be again minor variations
from ski area to ski area but if you
looked at Deer Valley for example which
I did and I asked this question during
my site inspection and the rate is just
right in there it's probably six percent
seven percent how many collisions and
I'm talking not ski accidents but
collisions where two skiers are hitting
against each other how many uh
collisions like that have you
investigated evaluated in your career
yeah I looked through uh sort of back
through the accident review data that I
keep and to just look at what you saw
the other day the incident report form
and maybe it's got something like an
additional patroller comment or a ski
instructor's incident report
um I looked through that and I figured
there have been about four thousand of
those that I reviewed out of about 44
000 accidents with just the incident
report form that I've looked at that's
all accidents but collisions about four
thousand and then things that really got
more investigated where there's things
like we're doing here
550 is so that's a
it's a lot of accidents and a lot of
collisions in those over a long period
of time sorry sorry I just wanted to
make sure nobody will think skiing is
safe anymore so
um
when you've done
um those evaluations uh what is your
role what are you trying to accomplish
as you evaluate those accidents well
sometimes we need to find
the cause mostly we want to know the
cause and certainly that's how you can
Target prevention but we also want to
learn circumstances sometimes we have
really bad injuries in these collisions
and it's important for us to make sure
we know is there somebody at fault or
people meeting the responsibilities and
so we're looking at that all the time
and part of that is we want to make sure
since we're all responsible as skiers
that includes the ski areas me you if
you're skiers that we share safety we
all do it together and we all have
responsibilities and if one of us is not
doing our job people get hurt and so
we need to evaluate
fault at times and that we maybe address
some people that we actually removed
from the mountain we've had people go
in cop cars off of the mountain but you
know we're serious about it we want our
skiers to know that we're serious about
it they feel okay bringing their kids
there that we're not just turning a
blind eye
so in your evaluation of these various
collisions what have you learned about
what the inherent risks of skiing are
well certainly
skiers
face a variety of inherent risks and
those are often codified into especially
in states that have a lot of skiing in
them like Utah or Washington State or
California you know there's there's what
they call like a ski safety Statute in
uh in the regs and so it will mention
many times it'll enumerate what some of
those inherent risks are another place
you can find those inherent risks are on
trail signs are mandatory here in Utah
and that they're publicly displayed but
also the ticket back sometimes that
varies from place to place but
um do you want me to list any of the
inherent risks sure yeah just to educate
the jury given your experience
investigating these various collisions
and just your experience as a long time
Advanced skier what are those inherent
risks objection your honor relevance
overruled
thank you uh yes so
things that you encounter as a skier
things that you could likely have a
problem with if you weren't paying
attention and weren't following uh your
your role your duties
of uh things that we would identify
under things like this gear
responsibility code which we can talk
about but but
train changes Forest growth bare spots
things that you might run into objects
lift Towers
grooming machines snowmobiles we try to
keep those off the hill when people are
around but you know that's part of the
sport people need to get lift
maintenance people need to get around
the mountain so uh snorting about being
there I'm sorry yes I was just going to
say what about inherent risks relating
to ski collisions and that's where I was
coming to so I wanted to give you the
broad brush and then say end things like
inbounds Avalanches you can actually get
even if they do the mitigation you can
actually get uh
into an avalanche in bounds and that's a
risk you hadn't seen identified for a
while but about five or six years ago we
started adding that one and collisions
gear collisions or even collisions with
lift towers and objects but skier
collisions as we know six to seven
percent of the accidents
we can eliminate some things but at
inherent risk you cannot and the
definition there is the risk is inherent
in the sport you cannot remove it
without fundamentally altering the sport
as it exists today so that means using
good
following our good responsibilities and
being prudent skiers we can reduce the
risk but we can't eliminate it
so does that mean that sometimes
collisions occur despite people
reasonably skiing on both sides of an
accident
yes that happens all the time and when
you investigate collisions do you
sometimes after a thorough review
conclude that you can't determine who
was at fall
yes that's common
so just to put that in another way
in your evaluations so will you come to
the conclusion that a certain accident
is and the evidence that you receive in
gathering information about it is uh
not clear enough for you to identify who
is responsible for it yes
let's talk about the skier
responsibility code you mentioned that
yes and it's been brought up before but
since you're the ski expert
let's have you teach us about it for a
second
I believe it is defense
second sorry
thought I had it right here yep it's
defense 91.
any objection to that being published or
I guess I should talk to the judge
91 is received
okay so let's put this up on the screen
it's also on your screen right there Mr
Bogger I think you guys yeah
turn it here so it's a little easier to
see okay so is this the skier
responsibility code you were referencing
earlier it is and it's actually changed
in the last
a few years but uh but that's the one
that was in existence at the time of
this accident okay got it 2016. 26
February 2016 February that's correct
okay and how do you know about this
skier responsibility code
well it's excuse me it's key to all of
the duties that we were just talking
about in order for people to skiers
for us to do our part and it's a
national code started back in the 60s
with the national ski patrol system
before they had professional ski patrols
at ski areas and
it's used all over
North America Canada has something
called the Alpine responsibility code
it's very similar it has a few more
details on it that I testified in trials
in Australia talking about a code that
they have again very similar to this but
these are basic rules of the road you
have to give people so you can put some
order into the chaos that is skiing you
know skiing is very dynamic as you know
if you're a skier and so you're trying
to put some basic rules in that people
who follow their common sense and oh go
ahead do you know are there ways that
skiers can become familiar with this
responsibility code yes this is uh
published at all skier is it's on trail
maps typically and you'd find them on
big trail signboards too at the ski area
websites will have it there's all sorts
of places you can go to find this but
it's it's everywhere okay and
um let's talk about the particular
points here I'll pull them out
maybe let's should we just go through
them one by one is that okay sure
however you want it okay so the first
one always stay in control and be able
to stop or avoid other people or objects
that seems fairly Common Sense yes
that's that's if that one doesn't work
the rest of them aren't going to work
and then the second one maybe is more
important people ahead of you have the
right of way it is your responsibility
to avoid them can you explain what that
means for skiers
yes and the presumption is when people
are skiing down a run the people in
front of you aren't going to have that
rear view like you would you'd have
you'd be in a better position as an
overtaking skier to see the people in
front of you
got it
um
three is you must not stop where you
obstruct a trio or are not
visible from above what does that mean
well again it's just about being visible
and so if there's a breakover in the
terrain and you were on the bottom side
of it the skier that's coming from above
isn't going to see you and so it's to
prevent surprises and again if you're
skiing in control if you're following
the first rule when you're coming up to
terrain changes that's one of the things
that skiers have to manage is they're
skiing their their speed their rate
their course and most importantly their
Lookout
that's what allows them even if they
come to a train change and there's a
let's say a small child taking his skis
off on the downside of that Hill you're
not going to run into him even though
that person might not be following the
code you're not following it either if
you just go tearing over the the heel
you have to be able to be in a position
to maneuver so you don't hit anything
okay so if a skier were
taking are you familiar with the term GS
turned yes giant slower if a skier we're
taking GS turns what principles here
should that skier follow
well with a GS turn and again just
backing up for a moment skiing is very
Dynamic it's people that are changing
positions relative to each other all the
time
and people are going at different speeds
people are using different styles and
you're mentioning one of them you know
short radius turn or slalom versus a
larger radius turn more rounded turn a
giant slalom and these are different
styles and they there's no prescription
for how you have to do it or even what
your ability is any of that there's no
speed limit I mean there's slow skiing
areas but there's no number so the idea
is skiers have to be able to be in
control and it's the lookout in a GS
turn you're going you're taking wider
swaths of terrain you're moving across
more you're using more of the available
heel space so again if there was
Trail density that was suggesting maybe
used to be skiing shorter radius turns
that would be a reason but typically
when people are skiing giant saw and
turns their speed is usually faster and
people that are skiing short radius
turns I mean if they try they can ski
quickly but most of the time it's the
turn is what controls your speed so if
you're making more of them you're
probably going slower what about uh
let's assume a skier is overtaking
another group they're skiing through a
group that's skiing slower what
responsibility does that skier have
well again as the overtaking skier
you're looking at the rule number two
people ahead of you have the right of
way and when you're coming into a group
you now have less space to maneuver and
your Lookout has to be sharper because
you have more things to focus on again
remember everybody's
not moving in unison they're they're
moving dynamically and and people can
turn suddenly and so again if you're a
prudent skier and this isn't necessarily
covered in the code but if I'm going to
make an Abrupt turn on a crowded run
that's a problem for me if I didn't look
I need to look up uh you know it doesn't
say you have to look uphill but so the
the code gets you just so far
and I think
if I may
one of the things about the code is if
you try to look at any one rule and say
for example in a collision because I
have to look at this all the time in
these investigations or when I'm
training people I would have to tell
them never focus on just one that's just
one part of the puzzle there's usually
something else and if I had a penny for
everything that was involved
the failure of the lookout
for example if I have two I might have
two skiers in a collision and both are
trying to be the the
not the uphill skier and I look at them
and I'm going but you were changing your
positions you had different speeds you
were merging and converging on each
other you both have the responsibility
for your Lookout it can't just be
straight ahead you have to be
looking and that's part of why you have
to go to number one and that's the king
and then you go through the rest of them
but you can't hang your head on
just one now in some accidents it may be
uh really prominent and you can weight
it that way but I'm just saying you need
to consider all of this and the lookout
you can't forget right so
um is there anything about
what can you tell us about the rules of
skiing reasonably that relates to skiing
within your ability is that is that one
of the rules well it's not a rule per se
but it is right here that you have to be
in control so that means for whatever
slope you're on whatever the snow
surface might be it might be a hard icy
day and you're going faster might be a
little harder to control your your speed
you know you need to then it's not that
different I guess from driving there
because you know if the weather is bad
and breaking distance is bad then you
have to give more room and I think
creating space is is a key but you have
to ski within your ability and you want
to assume that
maybe not everybody's doing the same
thing and and leave a margin okay so
what about if uh take an example of a
skier that may may have certain physical
disabilities
does that skier have the responsibility
to
um take account of those disability or
those limitations and ski appropriately
yes of course
um
let's go move away from this for a
second
um and ask you about a hypothetical
that connects to Dr sure's test me you
were here when Dr sure yes testified or
that was correct and he talked about
bindings releasing do you remember that
yes and do you have knowledge about how
bindings release in ski collisions yes I
do so if you were to assume a certain
skier came and hit another skier
directly in the back
at a high rate of speed would you expect
bindings to come loose the skis to come
off the skier objection you're on a lack
of foundation also not contained in his
report in the lease there is nothing
mentioning any binding release in
anywhere in the report
sustained
let's um
let's try take another hypothetical give
me a second to think it through
let's forget about bindings and use that
same hypothetical of someone skiing
directly into someone else's back
would you expect that person uh
to
launch over the next the the person they
hit in you know a couple feet down the
down the mountain same objection here on
our lack of foundation sustained
is there a space on the hill where
um
skiers
where you where you should where you uh
honey
think about it differently
if a skier were trying to
avoid collisions and Ski and a kind of
safe and cautious place on the hill
where should that skier go
well you could look for uh certainly
train within your ability and if you
want to be cautious you'd probably want
to be on easier runs and if you were
wanting to be away from
more people
specifically if you're concerned about
secure collisions and runs are getting
crowded these days
you know you pick a you pick the right
time or you wait for opportunities you
can wait for traffic to go by and then
you can go staying on the margins of the
Run
because you only have one side to defend
if you will so if if a skier were taking
short radius turns on the right side of
a run would would that be within the
um
parameters you've just described yes
uh I did cut you off a little earlier
when you were talking about the inherent
risks of
skier collisions the things you learned
about what the inherent risks are in
skiing invest investigating collisions I
want to make sure you've got out what
you wanted to on that point was there
anything else well I mean that's a a big
question
sustained
okay your honor may I
okay thanks for your patience sure
um
you personally went to the side of this
Collision correct I did and Were You
There When Mr Brill and maybe I should
ask first do you know Mr Brian Brill I
do and uh who is he uh he does
animations the ones that you've been
seeing here and he he does them all over
uh for ski accidents I think he does
other things too but he's very very
precise in laying out the terrain and
the features in the terrain you know the
trees are all the right height and the
Shadows are correct and all of that and
you were here and you'd seen the
animations before correct I have
objection your honor this goes beyond
the scope of his report there's no
mention of animations in the report
overruled at this point
how it's tied in sure I was just going
to ask that does the given that you've
been to the site of the Collision does
the animation to you accurately portray
the location
sustained as to relevance it doesn't
matter
it was a demonstrative of the other
Witnesses testimony okay
um
in this case
what did you review
I looked at all the deposition testimony
the documents and various forms we did
the site inspection
I I did work with Mr Brill on the
animations I talked to Mr draft strike
relevance sustained as to relevance why
don't we take our lunch break at this
time it's just a little afternoon and
we'll so we'll take a recess and return
at 1 30. thank you your honor
your questions in light of the Court's
earlier rulings
okay we'll see you back at 1 30. thank
you
thank you
the bailiffs are bringing in the jury
and getting them ready
no
until they're ready
Mr Bogger you can come back up to the
witness stand
of course
okay we're ready for the jury
foreign
thank you Mr Egan you may continue
all right Mr Bogger we just have a few
more questions and then we'll get you
off
stand here
first uh is it your opinion that both Mr
Sanderson and Miss Paltrow have the
responsibility to exercise reasonable
care
to avoid a collision with each other on
the day of their accident yes that's
correct and if and you're familiar with
Miss Paltrow's account of that Collision
correct yes I am have you heard her
testimony in the trial testimony that
she gave to this jury I have and you
also reviewed her deposition yes and uh
if you assume that her account is
correct
is it your opinion that she did comply
with the standard of care or this the
reasonable standard that you just said
that was her Duty
yes and if you assume her account was
correct did Mr standerson
comply with that Duty
no
and
um
why is that
well if you assume the facts that we're
looking at Miss Paltrow's version
then you'd have to conclude that at the
moment of the Collision
she was a skier below and was hit from
behind in that Collision
I know I said there were a lot of other
factors but in this case that seems to
be the key factor and that's where
the failure of someone's Lookout at the
last minute even if they can be in
control the entire time making great
solemn turns whatever it might be
but you can be a very good skier and you
can be skiing in control but if you have
a momentary failure and there is someone
below you of your Lookout
then you have a collision and by
definition if you have that Collision
that's not in control because you can't
stop it or avoid anything below so by
definition that's skiing out of control
even if it's momentary
did you review the
evidence relating to Deer Valley's
paperwork and
obtaining of information about this
accident I did and do you have
knowledge of the standards for ski
resorts in terms of that kind of a
investigation of an accident yes and did
Deer Valley comply with that standard
yes based on the facts that they had in
front of them yes
and did you see any evidence of
um
inappropriate documentation
no what I reviewed looked like it would
meet the industry standard of care it
would be very similar to all the ski
areas that I visited and know I'm
familiar with their record keeping and
so forth these are typical business
records kept in the course of business
in your experience
thoroughly investigating over I think
you said 500 ski collisions do you
sometimes conclude that the evidence
does not allow you to determine who is
at fault all the time yeah you sometimes
you just don't have enough information
sometimes you have conflicting
information and you just you know
there's plausible versions and you can't
you can't know which one's right and you
just have to realize that you're not
going to be able to determine fault so
that's that's common enough
that's all my questions thanks thanks
miss van Orman
I'm going to be really really quick with
you in fact we're just going to do the
opposite of what you just testified to
so you were just asked if Miss Paltrow's
version of the accident assuming that
was true would Mr Sanderson have
violated the skier's responsibility code
we're going to flip that you've heard Mr
Sanderson and Mr Ramon's version of the
accident assuming those were true
they would have complied with the
skier's responsibility code correct
correct and Miss Paltrow would have
violated this year's responsibility code
that's correct all right and in fact the
skier's responsibility code it applies
to all skiers they all have to follow it
right that's correct no matter if
somebody has a disability in their eye
or if they're turning to look at their
children to watch them ski
all skiers have that responsibility at
all times that's all I have thank you
thank you three again
thank you Mr Bogger thank you you may
step down
Mr Egan you may call your next witness
or Mr Owens this time thank you
MD
so Dr Ashley
to tell the truth
do you swear that the testimony you are
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
God
thank you you can have a seat good
afternoon
Would You Begin by stating your full
name and spelling it for the jury
yeah Julie
that's a
s-t-e-b-e in
e d g l e y
EP
okay Dr edsley are you employed yes
where are you employed at the University
of Utah
and uh are you over the acquired brain
injury
division
yes uh Physical Medicine
in rehab is my specialty and uh I'm over
uh that uh suction how old are you sir
uh
okay and just background undergraduate
degree where was that
I uh studied psychology with a pre-med
emphasis at BYU
um my med school training was in Chicago
we had Louella University in Chicago
and I did a four-year residency in the
Physical Medicine and Rehab at the
University of Utah and then did you go
there did you stay at the University yes
and have been for how many years
My overall
to one he
he 20. yes okay and do you do you hold
an endowed chair at the University I do
you teach are you a professor there
I do and you personally had an acquired
brain injury is that true
yes uh yes so I had a stroke in 2001.
um
21 years ago
and uh
did that event play a role in your area
of study
you did
um I was initially announced for a
residency training in ophthabology
actually
I took a one year off to
deal with the recovery ax facts of my
stroke and I've been a beacon Physical
Medicine and Rehab residency training
are you board certified in your
specialty I am
you are a physician MD correct yes and
um
do you deal with people other than
stroke people other acquired brain
injuries so um
again
my practice so I it's a very busy at
practice
95 of my practice
deals with acquired brain injury
and what is that
as opposed as opposed to brain injury
like if a baby is born
with a brain injury
required so uh uh a quieter the brain
injury uh encompasses Strokes uh
traumatic brain injury concussion
and
um Myriad of other brain injuries
related to you know surgery
um in the oxygia
near drownings
anoxia Is Like Oxygen deprivation yes
okay like it and maybe a child who's
found at the bottom of the swimming pool
rehabilitated brought in and they come
and see you yes
about how many patients have you seen
in your career so I I
have let's see uh um I see about
15 separate encounters per day over 20
years
that equals over 65
patient Encounters of acquired brain
injury thank you and do you consider
yourself an expert in brain injuries
yes
and the fact that you have personally
had an acquired brain injury does that
also give you additional Insight it
makes me
um
kind of a unique uh you know not that I
have a experienced
have you reviewed voluminous records in
this case I have
so the court complaint
records and reports from the VA hospital
is that fair yes about a thousand Pages
or so yes and uh deposition transcripts
Gwyneth Paltrow Terry Sanderson
the daughters Sam Goldstein Dr Fong all
of those yes that's correct and medical
records also of the Park City InstaCare
cognitive FX Sam Goldstein
if you review those yes
uh
do you believe that you have the
foundation to render expert opinions in
this case I do
the jurors have already heard
that the patient uh or I should say Mr
Sanderson has
um
a mild traumatic brain injury do you
agree or disagree
I think I have a poured over the records
um
I I think it's possible
okay but
uh the
more use Arc any conclusive
did you tell me that uh
the most important things you look at
are how long they're unconscious and how
long they've lost their memory amnesia
now that's correct so uh that's uh going
by the Cantu
concussion grading system which is
uh preferable because it's uh the most
objective
and not relying on subjective
symptoms from any patient okay so a
concussion if so if you hear someone as
a concussion
are those that your two lead questions
how long were you out
and how long is your memory out exactly
all right and apply that to Mr Sanderson
would you
so Yeti is uh one next layer whether he
lost Consciousness now
um
uh let me me be a clear
so um
let's say Divine con consciousness
so
when you are unconscious you are totally
lifeless and limp
not speaking not moving
that's unconsciousness
I I
based on the
records uh there is a very
inconsistent Africans
that he did in fact lose Consciousness
so I I am not able to state that
I can conclusively
okay what do we know about for instance
uh
Christensen was the ski instructor he
testified to no loss of consciousness
are you with me yep and uh
Brad falchuk has not gone yet
Miss Paltrow has Paltrow has stated no
loss of consciousness Craig Ramon did
say loss of consciousness have I sort of
summarized some of the people who talked
about that yeah and uh the uh plaintiffs
uh
himself his uh said you know a loss of
conscious is
um five minutes and then again a later
10 minutes okay so Mr Sanderson kept
changing what he was telling people
right I don't know a few seconds five
minutes
then 10 minutes true yes and I think uh
that is uh why it's uh important to
clarify
loss of consciousness with uh the post
traumatic amnesia
so
um so
the plaintiff
will not remember
how long he was unconscious if he at all
he will remember
the first
memory he had of that event
okay and then Consciousness I heard you
say five minutes and I just want to be
clear uh
one of the ways we rate
sort of the severity of the concussion
is
um
very short to no concussion up to five
minutes and then over five minutes so is
that true so why all right do I clarify
no loss of the consciousness
but
post
traumatic Amnesia is a great one
concussion
thank you uh
Whitney Smith I guess was another
provider who said no loss of
consciousness are you aware of that
testimony
I I am I I don't recall okay when he was
the toboggan person yeah she asked she
quizzed them I guess but let me move on
okay so uh even under even if Ramon's
testimony is believed
uh that that would put him only in the
second category less than five minutes
yes okay and first category is
essentially no loss of consciousness
okay now let's go to Amnesia applying
what you've learned about Mr Sanderson
how long was his uh Amnesia after the
Collision
uh that is also a very ambiguous and
multiple reports
I so um
I
hear and uh read
that he had a conversation with a
Herrick christansen which he does
remember
which was you know uh dramatic and his
opinion so Sanderson remembers
Christensen yelling
true
so is that what you're referring to yes
that is the allegation yes okay and uh
he he remembers his friend
uh
Craig Ramon talking to him are you okay
are you okay
true yes okay so what does that tell you
about like length of amnesia
um it was
breathe yep I don't know okay so you
said two big things we look at for
severity of concussion
is uh
how long they're out and how long they
could forget things
um
yes
and
I will add
um
so
people
experiencing a brain uh trauma of a
period of
fogginess and you know that yes
uh the plaintiff himself said
uh quote I Wrong My Bell
I run okay at one point he said I had
I rung my bell I hear you go ahead so uh
I am not able to say you know so
so
um
yeah Eddie's uh probably uh it is likely
that he did have some
a confusion but uh but if
you have
he had no
loss of consciousness
and no post dramatic Amnesia uh your day
Canada via called a concussion all right
fair enough and confusion let's just
talk about that issue
um
he has memories at the actual incidents
I correct
prevention leading
I stand I suppose I I don't think doctor
that's when you do not answer
uh length of um
period of confusion do you remember what
he told the toboggan person Whitney
about whether he
do you know if what Whitney observed in
terms of his confusion level
no
um she she wrote alert and oriented
times for something
that's in evidence I'm asking him now to
comment on it overruled no Foundation
overruled it Mis uh if Whitney the
toboggan person observed no con uh alert
and oriented times four are you familiar
with that term yes and is it four out of
four yes like four is the best score
yeah
I I want to know what that scale means
please tell me
so uh let's see yeah oriented that to a
person
please
uh situation
and
and uh location please time all right
time yes I don't know okay president
plays time
uh situation did you say president
or present no person person
so uh all right and the jury's heard on
those issues so uh that's okay I asked
Terry uh would it surprise you if at the
InstaCare they found no confusion he
said no uh is that consistent with your
knowledge of the events yes
have you seen texts he was sending out
even at the bottom of the hill about
Whitney
I have uh heard about the text yes all
right uh
your opinion that uh if if Mr Sanderson
suffered a concussion and it was mild
it was mild leading
that's overruled go ahead
uh what's uh at the question again is it
your opinion that if Mr Sanderson
suffered a concussion it was mild
yes
yeah and is that based on the things
we've been discussing or are there any
other issues
um
loss of consciousness
Amnesia confusion
yeah
I'm just wondering are there other
issues we ought to hit before we move on
to your next opinion
to go to that issue
hey uh
elemented low of velocity impact
uh also low velocity impact what does
that mean so
he was not uh
going fast
okay what do you like
like
uh in a car accident uh he was not going
a car
okay
and you read for instance the
depositions where they discussed it was
actually kind of a slow fall yes
and that's important when determining
how hard the hit was or something for
the concussion severity yes thank you
any other factors we've missed I don't
think so all right let's go to your
second opinion here
none of the medical records
support
plaintiff's claim
that perceived symptoms of cognitive
decline are related to the ski Collision
is that your opinion
yes maybe I'll flip it around
comment on the his symptoms
uh
what what percentage of the symptoms
that he now complains of are related to
the ski Collision
you can't
really do that I I think um it would be
uh better to
um
analyze what he had going on his in his
brain before and after how they can to
listen please do that
so um
about the plaintiff in iron
in no way uh trying to uh pick on
the plaintiff
but uh he had a number of uh brain
conditions
he had a thrilled which he lost
he is eyesight in his right eye stroke
yes
he had
evidence of a microvascular disease
in his brain in his brain
um
and most probably you have most
importantly
he had evidence of a hydrocephalus
I cleared back in 2000
nine and
um a lot so uh let me talk about the
height of real selfless yeah and
okay let me make sure we get the whole
list though these are preceding brain
problems from his uh pre-collision true
yeah
whatever this exhibit is to the witness
and having him read off of that
no he's not reading off of it but please
turn it around
it's a different topic
go ahead
so that was not a prop that was getting
ready to show it but we'll we'll go on
yeah okay uh what do you stay yeah okay
I heard you say uh
with regard to pre-collision brain
problems that the plaintiff had stroke
microvascular disease hydrocephalus any
others
um not that uh showed up on the
MRI of his brain in oh nine he had a
history of migraines is that something
he'd put under that list or not
yeah
yes so
stand
okay
um
pardon me I didn't even strikes
I I couldn't hear you okay motion
granted I didn't even know what his
answer was going to be by the way I'm
just trying to get this list together
but
uh must disregard it thank you so
if you think of another one we ought to
talk about please tell me okay
uh uh you said you want to talk about
hydrocephalus what is that word
I'll address cephalos is uh we're the uh
can't recalls have
um
too much pressure
War
um a condition called normal pressure
ice
which is equally uh
kind of a devastating
um for me does hydro mean water yes what
does cephalus mean
um brain Okay so
water on the brain and then this is very
confusing
normal pressure hydrocephalus is not a
normal condition is that true not not
at all over overruled it's it I mean
when I see the word normal in a
diagnosis I think oh that's normal but
in this case
normal pressure hydrocephalus is or is
not a good condition
um it is a well recognized medical
condition
that is degenerative
in nature meeting it gets worse what the
time
about one
only one in 500
people between now the age
60 60 and 70 have this
and your dad gets worse with that time
you said hydrocephalus means water brain
what does that mean there's too much
fluid in the head or what so it
specifically a means that uh there is a
too much a fluid in the ventricles of
the brain and what's a ventricle again
um so fluid fields
um uh cavity is up at uh feed the
spinal column and eventually I get
reserved by uh the body and you said
it's Progressive just comment on that so
let's say there were no ski accident
comment on its progressiveness in Mr
Sanderson
so it's been
14 years since uh that he initially MRI
so that's
quite a bit a bit of a time
I would expect
symptoms
to a crop up like loss of a memory like
trouble with balance
okay
let's move on to
microscular Disease by the way was
I want to know if these things are
related
if someone has the hydrocephalus like Mr
Sanderson does he also have to have
microvascular disease no all right and
do you believe the microvascular disease
caused the stroke
yes okay so those two things are related
so go ahead
so I.E a stroke of how the central
retinal artery
is a harbinger of
feature Strokes
and a indication that there is my
microfascular disease so microvascular
micro means small is that right yes
vascular means like blood flow yes all
right so small blood flow so in late
terms
um
does that mean the passages of blood
flow are narrowed in his brain
yes
I stand I'm trying to get to the most
like eighth or grade level which is what
I understand yeah so comment uh
on on Mr sanderson's pre-collision brain
as it related to microvascular disease
please
so two on point so um
some
microvascular disease and I can cause
very small a stroke
which are
not able to uh be a detected by
uh scans MRI CT also uh a number two
microfascial or red disease
that is a
greater risk factor F4
a futurist stroke
do you believe this is is this your
opinion all symptoms
plane of claims
is explained
not by the Collision but by his
pre-accident conditions
trying to get his opinion out there your
honor
you can ask what his opinion is
yeah sustained okay comment on your
opinion on on that issue on the issue of
his his current claims
as it relates to his
pre-accident conditions
so
and he more likely uh than not scenario
and this
76 year old brain now
uh
concussion some Thomas
should only last for one to three months
there is a wide birth of the evidence
at that
when the concussion symptoms
last for longer than three months
yes
highly correlated with monetary gains
word litigation
explain that please monetary gains or
litigation go ahead
and relate it please directly to Mr
Sanderson
yeah this goes beyond the scope of his
expert report
would you approach please
shouldn't sustained
describe the answer to and the answer
question answered and then the jury is
ordered to disregard it
comment would you on the patient's
pre-existing anxiety and depression
so
yeah because I've been medicated
for a number of years for depression and
anxiety
those things play a role in his current
condition absolutely
just comment on that would you
so
um
also
one sometimes of
concussion
lasts for three months or longer
uh
anxiety and depression and other
psychiatric
conditions on are allowed the likely
cause of that prolongation
the last sentence uh
I missed the last word I'm sorry uh
prolongation prolongation thank you for
explaining that can you just comment
just a little further about that
what do you say a different way for me
would you yeah
yeah so um
obvious symptoms of a concussion should
last
manure more than three months
when
the symptoms of
concussion last longer than three months
you start looking for
and this is
High highly correlated with
underlining
depression anxiety
and other psychiatric
conditions
one thing you noted in your report was
plaintiff has a history of seeking
medical attention at an abnormal rate 72
times in 10 years is that your opinion
sustained
well comment on how frequently
uh
Mr Sanderson went to his doctors in the
tears prior to the Collision
so
Dia denote that he had an extensive
history of seeking heck here and what
does that tell you why is that important
um two things one I I either he has
many medical issues
before the Collision were
uh kind of hyper focused on
his symptoms and this pre-collision
we're talking about yes
and then
pre-collision
um
just as a part of aging
did he note a decline in his mental or
physical activity the Acuity level
so
what's an interesting uh
um
is within one month of the acquisition
he I went to uh his own family not a
doctor and said I am
I feel like I'm getting old this is
within one month before yes
and did he say I'm having a hard time
doing the things I've always done yes
overruled
and why was he why was he feeling that
way do we know yeah I
yeah so I I I'm just asking
do you have any thoughts on that issue
sustained
well using your medical opinion I'm just
wondering uh what does that tell you as
a reviewing medical expert Foundation
overruled
go ahead
I'm getting old and I can't do what I
used to do go ahead so
overruled
so
I have I had many patients over his age
see how the same thing yes
yes
um
and
I I think it's important to clarify
one thing so um
the brain is in a working
just like any other organ
with time he had a cruise
conditions problems
just like
any other organ
uh
the plaintive
had evidence
including objective evidence of Alan MRI
and things like that of
this these disease processes
for the clinician okay and this was the
stroke work up is that where he had the
Imaging yeah before and do you know of
any of their plaintiff's experts who
actually reviewed the stroke Imaging
before the Collision
overruled
did they
um are they named the plaintiffs experts
review The Imaging to your knowledge
not to my knowledge
and if we're trying to figure out hey
what's this guy's brain like before and
what's this blame guy's brain like after
it would be nice to put those side to
side wouldn't it and actually compare
yeah it would and uh now that's yeah
that's uh What uh the defense has a gun
yes all right let's just talk about
aging direct uh
have you seen
may I show him a document in your honor
before I publish it sure
defense exhibit 103.
and 103 B
I have and does that appear to be a true
and correct summary of Mr sanderson's
Health before the incident
it does okay and your honor move to
publish it
in the election we object your honor
it's it's what we've talked about before
there's a relevant medical information
there
I'm about to establish the relevance if
he hasn't established it yet
um I'm going to admit 103 and 103 B for
demonstrative purposes only to allow
this witness to illustrate their
testimony
can I is this okay for a minute sure
this is the same thing I just don't
trust technology so 103 uh
and doctor do you have a binder right in
front of you
oh can you see it right here yes oh
monitor
the first that the monitor wasn't
working can can we do the first uh third
all right uh can you see that okay
Doctor yes and is this the note you were
just talking about thinks he's gotten
old all of a sudden not doing things he
used to do
uh it is yes and then uh let's stay that
big then
blind and right eye were you familiar
with that
it was
and severely impaired in the other did
you see that in his medical records
I did
you see evidence that he walked into
walls before the incident
yes he would ask people standing on the
right side of his field of vision to
move so that he could see them
uh did you see that in the evidence yes
one of the reasons he retired was
because he had a stroke event that
deprived his Ox eye of oxygen impacting
his vision Did You observe that in the
evidence yes
we're going to go through all these it's
going to be leading your honor every
time
overruled
He adjusted his skiing at to one side of
the slope to try to avoid hitting others
in his blind spot Did You observe that
yes he had to be picky about what days
he skied to avoid days with lighting
that would further limit his depth
perception do you agree
did you see that in the evidence yes by
the way I mean if I if I close one eye
do I have depth perception is
it three
comment on that is it still
three-dimensional or is it now
two-dimensional you do one time yeah
his expert testimony or harm he's
calling you about aging overruled
okay so I'm closing one eye
does that hurt my depth perception or it
doesn't
that does just comment very briefly
well um uh you have I basically I got a
monologular
uh situation
um
and so
uh
depth perception will will be a severely
impaired
prostate cancer uh were you aware he he
to this day still has metastatic
prostate cancer yes
it's not like it was cure true
yeah
and he is severely hearing impaired did
you see that in the record yes his
difficulty hearing higher frequency
sounds like a woman's voice
did you see that yes hearing loss is
severe did you see that yes
a heart palpitations did you see
reference to that
yes and he was on two heart medicines
two heart uh just prior to the ski
Collision two blood pressure meds for
his heart yes is that is that related to
the palpitations or are those high blood
pressure issues separate from the
palpitations so
um
happy can be related to uh the heart
that you can be related to anxiety okay
do you have an opinion one way or the
other so I can download speculate okay
Mr Sanderson is 76 years old and
experiencing the effects of Aging do you
believe that
you Doug
we all are
is that a yes uh yes
microvascular disease we talked about
that moderate diffuse volume loss
atrophy
brain volume decreasing
did you note that that he had that prior
to the ski Collision so I read Italian
at the report yes and
what does that mean it do our brains all
shrink as we age
yes
some more than others
yeah talk about Mr Sanderson please
bring any atrophy yeah can be uh caused
by a number of of uh factors
a comment on Mr Sanderson please
um
why did he have that before
ski Collision
I've had it before
overruled
you know why he he had it I I don't uh
it's a vague
uh symptom finding
and it could be a cause by number of
things
commonly people who I drink alcohol it
excessively
commonly have brain atrophy but but
there are a number of
other causes
do you see any evidence in the VA record
that he sometimes drinks more than six
drinks a night
did and they did you see his advice from
his providers was
don't do that anymore
did we want you to abstain from alcohol
yes
idea to see that yes all right we're
going to move faster here
by the way it says moderate volume loss
so mild moderate severe are those sort
of the three categories yes
and
that's uh referring it to the MRI in
retinal artery occlusion we talked about
that that's the eye thing
and
clotting in arteries delivering blood to
brain is there anything you want to
comment that you haven't talked about on
that issue number nine
no no
I don't think suppression you've talked
about that anything more you want to say
about it
a depression and anxiety
if he says since the ski Collision I've
had more depression and anxiety than I
did before
what do you attribute that to
you so
any symptoms
else
three months
I would uh
tribute
to this
multiple factors not at the
accident they migraine we've talked
about let's go we're gonna March through
these very fast
in addition to uh
going now starting on 103 B12
did you know he had degenerative disc
disease in his back prior to the skeet
Collision
I did did you see reference to a foot
drop that he at least for a time he
actually was dragging his foot
I did weakness in his uh uh back and
spine yes loss of sensation did you see
that yes and just general back pain yeah
knee injury yes
yes and that was actually from a skeet
Collision do you recall this not a
collision a ski accident
yes shoulder injury shoulder problems do
you recall him having those
yes and hamstring injury right torn
hamstring yes osteoarthritis did you see
that yes and
what maybe more a relevant to uh this uh
case is at the austinyo arthritis
in the neck
region which would make
moving your head side to a site kind of
a painful word difficult that along with
the vision impairment
um
are I think relevant
all right uh
my partners here are telling me I should
wind up
uh
can you at least look at insomnia
respiratory problems for male sexual
reproductive Health lower urinary tract
issues kidney problems hyper
cholesterolemia
weight gain and restless legs are those
all conditions you saw in as
pre-collision medical records yeah why
are these things important when we're
talking about aging
is a long list
uh
some of the other user conditions are
more relevant than others but
but uh the
psalm
it's out that he is
76 and with uh 76 year olds
sometimes I have
multiple medical like conditions like
those and these are all pre-collision
events right pre-collision conditions
yes and what does that tell you in terms
of his his aging
like at 69.
well um
that he was
so I
like I said that before
we all are
yes and out there
so in the terms of the brain is in
Oregon
we are talk about
burning brain Reserve
and we talked about cognitive Reserve
brain Reserve can set you a go and down
and down
uh starting at around age at 25.
uh it goes down faster
with the time and aging okay a cognitive
Reserve
uh indicates
uh
that the patient's ability to cope
adapt
be resilient
and find the effect of work rounds for
that brain
decline which we are all
our
uh underwear going he had a very various
stages let me conclude here they're
about to stand up and criticize you for
not personally meeting with the patient
did you personally meet with Mr
Sanderson no and what did his tree
actual treating providers at the
University of Utah or excuse me the VA
Veterans Administration people
what did they show on their all their
neuro side testing
so
um yeah
well yeah
meet and exam and the plaintiff because
I think it would be a kind of a
condescending that to a ham and all too
old to me to go over a totally normal
physical exam
as
the uh
medical and doctors yeah the VA had well
documented records and they normally
they documented High average to Superior
and essentially all categories
stand
can you comment on their findings in
terms of some kind of
graph
yeah I think you're referring to the
neuropsych test correct just give us and
then I'm sitting down give us a couple
two sentences on that would you
so yeah
psych test is really uh
like an MRI of the actual mind and its
function and what was it as to Mr
Sanderson after the Collision
uh
he had three
neuropsychat tests and it was
Superior to above the average thank you
yeah those are all my questions thanks
we'll take a short recess right now
thank you
foreign
you can step down we'll take a 10 minute
break 10 minutes
let him know
thank you
sir
judge well the jury is not their
Commandments in an issue
yeah have him stop at the door go ahead
Mr Owens
so after this Witness
uh there are three Witnesses who haven't
been able to testify and so they're
going to testify by deposition
are they ready to go on Carrie Oaks
because we
we withdrew that one but we want to know
are they ready
and are you reading our parts too
we handed them yeah we got them about 15
minutes ago right it's just a matter of
reading them though
I just need to know because otherwise we
wanted to play video of ours
but you know if the court wants us to
read them we'll read them
your honor we can't uh
Dr Fong's video as you know took quite a
while we don't have that time if they
want to call Carrie Oaks and rest
so our video is 15 minutes no but it's
our we're entitled to our talking to so
can we do it on paper your honor
okay
what was the last question I was I
didn't we just do it all on paper the
reading back and forth we don't have
time to review this for sex are you fine
with reading the deposition
Norman is talking with James right now
about it right but we're talking about
like we're going live here
right and we've handed this to us you
know 15 minutes ago we had our we gave
them our part a couple hours ago James
is right here I don't know who well did
you talk to Kristen I did not but as I
understand Kristen is
we'll go along with that if we can get
Dr Bain but I'm not sure we can even get
Dr babe except Kristen in here would you
two o'clock for sure tomorrow afternoon
all right well let's let's finish with
this witness and in the meantime maybe
it'll sort itself out if not I'll have
to make a decision I'm trying to contact
Dr Bain right now okay
let's have the jury come in
let's go
Mr Sorensen
thank you
Dr Edgeley thank you for being with us
today and
overcome a great deal to be able to
be so accomplished and we appreciate
that
um
I'm going to go through a few questions
pretty quickly and I just asked if you
wouldn't mind asking answering them yes
or no because they should be yes or no
questions and I think we can move this
process along
is it true or is it the case that you're
paid 500 an hour for records reviewing
700 an hour to be here
I I
believe you I had it about that
information and I I have that is correct
that error is
an opportunity cost
by my
not being had my irregular practice
I'm not here for money uh
I get paid
um
to her office said that the Opera
Opera caused by my not being at my
irregular clinical practice
so that that is yes though those those
numbers are correct yes okay thank
you and is it true that and and as
defense counsel pointed out you did not
ever meet with or see uh Terry Sanderson
correct yes okay
so you were paid to review records and
do sort of a forensic records analysis
correct
yes
we went over what you had reviewed in
preparation to give and offer your
opinions and I didn't see that you ever
reviewed the records of Dr Bame is that
correct
I I don't
think they ran under given that to me
okay
okay so that is correct you did not
review that
uh I I don't think so okay
what about the records of Dr Wendell
Gibby
yes
you did review them or you did not yeah
I did a review uh the devastation of uh
Dr Ray Gibby
okay
that was not on the list of things that
you said you relied on for your opinion
are you aware of that
uh no I was not
okay
so is it your position that you did rely
on some of Dr Gibby's records to
formulate the opinions you've offered so
far
so I did rely on a a
Dr Gibby yes okay
and I did also not see that you ever
reviewed the deposition of Whitney Smith
the EMT that we've heard from in this
case is that correct
I think that's correct
in order to see that you reviewed the
deposition of Carlene Davidson
is that correct
who is she she's the plaintiff's uh
former girlfriend that's offered
testimony in this case so I did a review
uh hooray definition
okay
and what about the man named Craig Ramon
did you ever review his deposition yes
okay
neither of those last two were on the
list of things that you say you rely on
so you were in fact partially relying on
them for your opinions yes okay
I think we already covered it but you
did a forensic document review in this
case is that correct yeah yeah yes okay
and in a nutshell and I don't want to
put words in your mouth but you offered
uh five main opinions in your expert uh
support that you provided to us is that
correct
right
and really because of court rulings
we're going to focus on two of those is
that all right yes okay
your first
opinion that
plaintiffs when or defense excuse me
defense counsel went through with you is
that compelling evidence indicates that
plaintiff's concussion was mild and that
he lost Consciousness only momentarily
if at all is that your opinion yes
so you do believe that there's a chance
he did lose consciousness
and there is a chance but uh
but more likely uh than not
no loss of consciousness
I am not seeing any compelling in
evidence to a
four-wheel layout otherwise
when you say compelling evidence you're
stepping into the place of the jury to
weigh evidences and correct
is that a yes or no
I
think
when you weigh the the number one
opinion that you have that you've
offered in this case
and you say that it wasn't compelling
is that because you weighed evidence
I read
poured over many reports
many which will were
consistent
and
I'm a lab tattoo uh
Wanderer
did he actually lose Consciousness or
not
down with no
uh I would say more likely than not yeah
the answer is no
okay
and for the reasons that you gave when
defense attorneys were asking you
questions those that's why you say that
it was more likely than not that he did
not lose consciousness yes
okay do you need to have a loss of
consciousness in order to sustain a
concussion
no
and is there dispute among your peers
and those of your specialty into the
actual definition of what unconscious
means
I don't think so so all of those that
are in your specialty would say that a
loss of consciousness
um
involves
I don't want to put words in your mouth
but lifeless and Limp is the way you put
it is that correct
so if we've heard testimony before this
that
you can be
unconscious or have a loss of
consciousness but still be somewhat
awake just disoriented or not alert
that's not correct
not bad
disorientation not loss of the
Consciousness yes okay
is it possible that the Amnesia that you
talked about with
defense counsel
is or could account for Terry
sanderson's inconsistent testimony about
how long he may or may not have lost
consciousness
yes
so that is a that is a very real
possibility in this case
it actually uh
you cannot
oh man telling your own unconsciousness
so so then we would be forced to rely on
the testimony of those that were there
or those that reported what they had
seen yes okay
we've heard some testimony earlier uh
about a triggering event are you aware
of things that could be considered a
triggering event
yeah the concept yes okay
is Alzheimer's disease caused by a
triggering event typically
no okay okay is dementia caused by a
triggering event no okay
is NPH caused by a triggering event
no okay
can the presence of mph exacerbate a
concussion or the symptoms I'm in
uh yeah the accounting and Theory but
only
for a brief imperative at a time breathe
meaning
weeks two months not certainly and not
seven years
the jury's heard a lot of testimony
about a condition called PCS or
post-concussive symptoms are you aware
of that condition yes
so is it your testimony that
the presence of NPH could not be a risk
factor in possibly leading to PCS
let me uh I'm back out of this so um
you should be aware if you're not
already you know I've had the DSM-5
which is at the
list of psychiatric conditions
um the fifth and most current edition
ourselves that
caution last
a more than three months
look for other causes
and and I I believe that they have a
totally eliminated
PCS from about their
diagnostic manual
so and I don't want to miss that you're
the answer you just gave me but is it
your opinion then that PCS and NPH are
not related at all then
you're asking me uh to a state a
categorical answer
yes
no
I cannot say that there is no
small you know
uh Association
okay so when Dr Bain for instance
testifies that it's rare but PCS can
occur after the occurrence of a
concussion is is that accurate in
testimony
and what Lang had to so I I have an
issue without the term peace
because I don't think it's
so we're as it was he a valid
condition
it's not
uh at least in a vs world
it's a not recognize yet he has a
condition now
okay so and maybe I in artfully asked
the question but essentially if I hear
what you're asking what what your
response was and again I don't want to
restate for you but you're you're coming
at this from a psychiatric perspective
where PCS might be more of a clinical or
medical diagnosis is that correct
no okay
can anxiety and depression be risk
factors for possibly having PCS
again I I take ESU with uh the uh Term
pscs Policy discussion syndrome okay
what about and I think we're talking
about the same things but I I believe
I'm talking about post-conco concussion
symptoms
and I don't know that they refer to the
syndrome anymore is that correct yes
okay so if I you want to talk about uh
post concussion symptoms
uh we I can I have a dialogue yes and
then and maybe that's my my fault for
misstating it before I'll ask you the
same question then can NPH be a risk
factor for post-concussive concussive
so
NPH is a chronic
degenerative disease
I've had
he has likely a excess repeated
by a number of uh things
uh the
immediate yeah for I aftermath of
concussion being one of them
but
more likely much more likely than not
the concussions
sometimes would have long you know years
ago gone away
and what we're left with is
uh
a brain that he knows
MP
M
microvascular disease history of stroke
and is
76.
okay and and you said a history of
stroke I want to make sure the jury's
clear uh Mr Sanderson had a stroke-like
event in his eye is that what you're
referring to when you say stroke
uh my only uh be uh clear to uh the
journey so um the American
stroke and a hard hit Association
um
considers a
red red Lino artery occlusion he has a
historic effect
not a stroke like event a stroke
okay but there's no uh scans and you've
poured over many in this case that show
any sort of brain bleed or or
any issues besides the mph and other
issues that we've talked about that
would be related to that stroke event is
that correct
yes
and did you read anywhere
in the medical records that you poured
over
that he had any sort of
NPH symptomology before the ski crash in
2016.
NPH
symptoms all right yes
okay what are those I think they're
called the Triads sometimes what are the
three main symptoms of NPH
so
this is a very lame man's way of
explaining it yet but you have cognitive
deficits
including memory
loss
you will have
imbalance
and uh that again uh lead to uh Falls
and you have
urinary
incontinence and continents
loss of uh the
function of holding urine in your
bladder
so just to recap those those the Triad
is is memory issues Ataxia and then
incontinence is typically how that's
diagnosed correct yes
okay and you do not see any of those
symptoms in Mr Sanderson
for the ski crash in 2016.
uh before 2009
and what were those symptoms that you
read well now before
2009 that's it correct but uh yet it was
commented on the MRI of a 2009
and
given about those symptoms are Insidious
uh in another onset
happening over
years
maybe a dank uh decades
uh 14 years later
uh
I I'm not at all surprised
to a fine uh
the plaintiff
experiencing memory and loss of balance
issues
okay and did you review any of the MRIs
taken of his brain in 2017 after the
Collision yes and did those MRIs that
you reviewed did those show any sort of
a worsening of this NPH
um the commented on it
I I don't know
give
the
scan
showed Rising
okay so you don't know one way or
another if it worsened or not but they
did mention that it that condition was
present yes and
um
that NPH is a clinical diagnosis
verified by rail Radiology findings
but nobody had diagnosed his NPH before
as having the Triad that we talked about
before
correct
uh I I now have to see any mansion
uh yes okay
and
you were asked a lot about
Plato's medical conditions we had a
board up here we had a whole list here
um
did you read anywhere in the depositions
that you reviewed that any of the
laundry list of medical medical issues
that the plaintiff mayor may not have
had before the event kept him from being
a world traveler or on the go or even
skiing that day
the effect happened
three weeks earlier
um he said to uh he was a primary care
physician
I feel like I'm getting old
that is
likely based on uh as a us setted that
in longer laundry list of conditions now
if there were
taxing their
uh no one
condition is that
problematic about how the complication
of there was like various
conditions do weigh on
a person
both physically and psychologically
but then if if that is the case Doctor
how do you you reviewed some of the
daughters depositions as you said
how do you account for their accounts of
what happened with their dad directly
after the ski crash in 2016.
I'm not going to make out the excellent
claim that there was not a transient
decrease of function
up to uh three months
but uh Beyond three months at a time
what I could decline he had
was more likely than not already the
ball was already rolling
okay
you testified earlier that you've been
an expert in many cases that have gone
on to litigation do you remember when
you testified of that
yes
have any of those cases been ski crash
cases
so this is your first uh ski crash
related expert testimony
yes
do you know what confabulation is
yes and what is that will you explain it
for the jury please
yeah regulation uh
means making uh making us
information up
and it's it's not just lying per se
right it's not just you're grabbing it
out of thin air there's a little bit
more of a clinical uh definition for it
isn't that correct
I I don't know where uteri going with
this
was is it's not confabulation is an
actual medical condition it's not just
creating lies correct
and I I can be he uh related to a
medical like condition yes
is it often seen in situations where
people have had a brain injury
yes okay
so inconsistent testimony by the
plaintiff
may be attributable to confabulation if
his story is to be believed that he has
a TBI
so I had to
point that uh
symptom
Elation to have the brain
enlarged brain injury
sure it's possible
but but
plenty of other things could account for
that symptom of a can abilation
sure but it is possible as you just said
correct yes
from the 2009 to the last scam that you
saw and I don't know when that was
probably the 2017 scan
um
have you seen any of his symptoms the
symptomology that you reviewed earlier
getting progressively worse from an
actual Imaging standpoint
no
um but we're talking about uh clinical
and diagnosis he's
backed up you know only backed up
by Imaging
sure but there's no physical you can't
point to any scans that say this is
different than it was in those early
scans in 2009.
now we're what I necessarily expect to
do you know what the medical term
discordant means
uh yeah okay uh
we uh dealt with uh
often use that
okay and what does it mean
well
it means uh Loosely but things that
don't make sense and don't add up
okay
you've been asked a lot about Mr
sanderson's medical records and
Radiology reports that you reviewed I'm
going to show this first page of
plaintiff's exhibit six
do you see this Radiology report right
here
yes okay I want to I'm going to zoom in
here for uh for all of us and I've moved
up to avoid the address
sorry about that
you want a Sharpie
do you read that uh that paragraph that
starts with the word findings do you see
that
yes
now will you just read that first
sentence for us right there
3 and 10 and demonstration of a
prominent I think trivial system
discordant with mild cerebral volume
loss in the solical
and prominent
now
you have the degrees and I don't so does
that mean that the prominent ventricular
system the issue with that that
ventricular system that you described
earlier is discordant or not related to
it or different from
the mild cerebral volume loss
of prominence
is that what that means
so
I
I don't I don't so suppose how do I
get into the brain of the Enduro
radiologist but uh but that is a
um validate conclusion so that's why
again that's my Layman's approach of
reading a medical record and I recognize
you have that and I respect your
position
but the medical records that you
reviewed
discordant is usually used before
describing this ventricular issue that
you described earlier isn't that correct
I I think um we're talking about to a
separate things uh the enlarged
ventricles
as a separate issue
at the mild cerebral athonium loss
and short of going well beyond both of
our expertise and sounding more like an
idiot that I'm sure I already do I think
we'll leave that one there
but you
these aging conditions that you describe
is it also within the possibility of
medical certainty that you've offered
your opinions
that Terry sanderson's condition could
be in fact related to post-concussive
symptoms
literature shows but but
so I would say much more likely yet than
not
uh
correct
yes if orders anything is that possible
let me just check with co-counseling I
think that's everything I have for you
so if other Witnesses reported massive
changes directly after this ski crash in
would you also attribute those massive
immediate changes to the aging process
reinstate the question sure
if other Witnesses
ex-girlfriends and daughters
report massive changes in the plaintiff
after the ski crash of 2016. would you
also attribute their
discussion of those massive changes to
regular aging
this is a complex question
uh he had
distress over a very real
rib fractioners
he had a psychological and physical
symptoms
that
do you influence you know what he had
patience Global functioning
rep fractures healed
bumps and bruises heal
what we're left with long-term
so
I I don't disagree with the
the fact that
people around
the exploitative
there are more big changes in his
physical and
psychological and function immediately
after
how the entry
but
now there was
brain related issues
should have resolved Within
weeks to a few months and and what we're
left with
is
he
76 well
uh
69 year old
the time brain with multiple problems
sure
but looking over the medical history
that like you did
you see that Terry Sanderson continued
to try to seek treatment for something
that was going on that he attributed to
be fairly related to this accident
correct
I would say yeah that out that day
medical attention seeking Behavior or
assertive
um
before and and
said by his uh primary care physician
visit uh the week the three weeks
earlier
and
that was likely a ball about
ruling so he was interested in his
health before the ski crash you've
testified to that correct
yes so he would be very interested in
anything that he have used he viewed to
be very acutely changed isn't that also
correct yes it will be part of that
pattern to continue going to the doctor
a lot
up until you think that you're going to
get some sort of resolution of your
symptoms isn't that correct
uh I I don't suppose to I know what was
I going on and how they playing it if
some money okay thank you very much
doctor I appreciate it
from the back here
last question
what do you perceive to be Terry's life
expectancy going forward
I have no
information to base a piano on that
thank you doctor
Mr Owens
I'm going to read you what you told me
your opinions are on redirect or on
direct and then I want you to see tell
me if anything has changed as a result
of cross-examination
the compelling evidence is that
plaintiff's concussion was mild and that
he lost consciously Consciousness only
momentarily if at all is that still your
opinion yes plaintiff's post-collision
neuropsychological evaluation shows no
evidence of impairment is that still
your opinion
it is
none of the plaintiff's medical records
support his claims that perceive
symptoms of cognitive decline are
related to the ski Collision
it's at this point yes
another way of saying that is all
current symptoms
are explained by his pre-collision
uh
aging and degenerative diseases
overruled
much more likely and
likely up and not yes
yes and you are asked about a a new word
confabulation like lying
you were asked about that right yes
did you review the deposition of Jenny
Sanders Sanderson
the daughter yes did you observe she
said that her dad would in fact be
dishonest
in order to get money
yes
that's not an Evidence
it is
just overruled
and that he seeks attention and the the
notoriety of this case makes him feel
powerful did you read that
I did
and uh
on our little break he said it's
outrageous you said something was
outrageous that they would assert
something what do you remember what it
was
his current conditions are related to
the ski Collision
what what's
am I throwing you
now uh I'm uh being picking my words
very wisely thank you
the narrowest psyche
uh evidence
and uh this uh psychiatric evidence
you have long
evidence to a support
have that one
a
concussion like
this electric uh concussion lasts over
yeah you know months
uh there is a high concordance rate
with
the patient being
involved in litigation
and
and also media attention
both
of his proper testimony overruled I was
asked how he explained
post accident
both of which
are hyper real
in this case
hyper real means what
very well real real
very real what is hyper real I missed it
so uh so it's uh just a a cake
term
for extremely
you know so extremely real
what is again extremely real
the factors of
this
litigation
and the factors of the media attention
around
his
concussion case so what if what of those
things is hyper real
what are they doing to him about his
current symptomology well so
I'm trying to understand this response
here overruled it goes to the weight
you gotta down it down for me please
at the fact that this is uh the first
Lego lacchaeus op-ed is yeah ever
televised in Utah
mix it
hyper real
in what way to sander to Mr Sanderson
what is that doing to him those facts
just trying to understand his culture
maybe you could go into a little bit
more of the background behind this
opinion
yeah I'm trying to understand the point
you're making
um and then what it's based on
so you're saying
this very litigation and the media
attention is impacting Mr Sanderson is
that your opinion
overruled as a preface to the question
absolutely okay and then how
so
uh the
litigation so uh
a lot of money is in play here
and how is that affecting Mr sanderson's
symptoms
you can't sustained
so
I'm being told to sit down have a nice
day
Sorensen
just one question for you Doctor uh is
hyper real a medical term
so that's
has no basis in any sort of medical
literature I would
say
extremely real
uh
real relevant
okay but again you never
conducted your own psychological
evaluation of the plaintiff correct yeah
so that would be pure speculation about
his motives or anything like that based
on
a number of
studies and mend analysis of uh
case cases
similar to this so case studies but
nothing directly attributable or
applicable to doctors
studies uh
analysis of uh actual
um how things about our end of the
medical literature
great thank you very much
okay you may step down thank you
you ready for your next witness or
should we take our last break
okay we'll take a short recess
short recess thank you
I can see that
good I guess I'm karaoke okay we just
have questions and I'll respond as
karaoke so Noreen could do it that's
what I had
to be good
I think it's nice to have both
of one member from each team
so I have the hard copy are there any
objections
okay I'll follow along if you'll key me
in on where you're at
okay thank you
we're taking a short break before you
begin
so your honor
yes one other thing on Dr Richard Bain
on the bottle
we don't know this yet but we would like
to propose that to hit Dr Bain and if
it's okay with the court and we have him
testify it uh nine or even 8 30 8 45
Thursday morning
for a very short rebuttal can we deal
with this at five let's do it at five
thank you well it's hard for us to
propose it if it's not approved and
you mean you're you're uh he's waiting
for the word from you well that's that's
part of it here this week is his wedding
he had an emergency medical procedure
it's his wedding his daughter's wedding
oh okay
he had an emergency medical procedure we
notified the opposing Council about
three or four months ago that he
couldn't do his
attempt trial and so well I'm not sure
when your rebuttal case is but if that's
when your rebuttal case is that's fine
we can come a little early on Thursday
getting back to carry Oaks the witness
how are you going to allocate the time
between the parties
based on the time of the questions that
they asked well so apparently there's
one question for the defense and the
rest of it's for the plaintiff
so whatever however that works out to be
ours was about 15 minutes long they
proposed I think
half an hour or 45 minutes of addition
Al questions
you have designated her as a witness and
we only wanted 15 notes if you want to
just let us do our 15 minutes why don't
we do this Council
in response
so let's let's go ahead and change
questionnaires depending on which side
has asked for that question and then
I'll be able to keep track of the time
literally your honor I would say their
time is probably
five minutes of the
total are you fine with five minutes
okay then five minutes of the time we'll
go to the defense and the rest will go
to the plaintiffs
okay I wasn't involved
all right thank you
okay
let's wait for the other side
would you like me to go get them your
honor yes okay yes please thank you
foreign
okay we're back on the record uh Council
are present and parties are present Mr
Owens yes thanks
so we're thinking this uh Harry Oakes is
going to go about a half hour
and then we're trying to figure out how
to best use that other half hour sure uh
one option is
well here's the question how strictly we
now have essentially one full day of
evidence left
how strictly are you keeping us to like
four hours each left
strict
strict so when you run out of time
you're done
okay so
um
and I'm trying to be mindful of the jury
so depending how much time is left then
we'll call Terry Sanders back to the
stage uh back to the uh
Pulpit we're talking tomorrow no if we
have time before tonight five okay okay
thanks
all right ready for the jury
explain to the jury what we're doing I
will okay thank you
take your seat yes
yes sir do you want do you do you swear
me in did that children
no I think not the lawyers will point
out any errors in your reading
that yeah
what page are we starting on so
um
we are starting the funny thing
okay
great thank you
and who's doing the questioning Miss
abarama okay
impersonating
them use your deepest voice
don't make objections
thank you you may be wondering why why
miss van Orman is seated as a witness
that we are now going to read a
deposition old school style
so the the witness name is Terry Oaks
Carrie
thank you for that correction
it's listed two ways in here Kerry Oaks
and the person that will be reading
Carrie Oaks part is Miss Christian van
Orman and the questioner will be Miss
abarama
you may proceed starting on Page Six
Judd would you like me to State the page
number and the line number I think if
you right now just whenever you skip
areas tell me where you're going okay
okay which is otherwise we don't need to
do the lines yeah
all right starting on page six good
morning Miss Oaks could you spell your
name for the record yes it's k-e-r-i and
Oaks is o-a-k-s
and do you know about what year you
started working at Deer Valley it's page
12 your honor
1990 actually that was a couple yeah
about that area give or take a couple of
years
page 16. okay when we talk about the
incident or the ski Collision or the ski
crash or similar words let's just agree
right now that we're talking about the
incident that occurred on February 26
2016 involving Gwyneth Paltrow and my
client Terry Sanderson is that clear yes
okay now I would like to go through some
of the parties to this case do you know
my client Terry Sanderson not Beyond
seeing him on the hill that day
okay have you had any other contact with
him prior to that or subsequent where I
spoke with him or no
okay what about Gwyneth Paltrow how long
have you or before this incident do you
know Gwyneth Paltrow that may have been
the first time that I skied with her
family I don't recall exactly how many
days I skied with them
page 18.
okay one or two ski trips you've skied
with Gwyneth Paltrow correct correct
sorry if you could speak up correct
okay what about Brad falchuk do you know
who he is yes
did you ski with him on the ski trip
that involved this ski crash in what
capacity
I mean did you meet him yes we met him
okay and I understand you were teaching
primarily one of the children with some
of the children is that correct not his
children
okay whose children were you teaching
Gwyneth
and who are they apple is specifically
who I was with
okay and were all of the ski trips with
Brad falchuk and Miss Paltrow's children
they were all on the trips with Gwyneth
Paltrow correct correct
you didn't ski with Brad falchuk or the
children on the trips where Miss Paltrow
was not there correct correct
did you know who Greg ramonis no
do you know who Eric Christensen is yes
how do you know Eric through Deer Valley
we work together
how long have you known Eric since I
don't know the exact amount of years but
most of the time that I've been an
employee here I've known him
page 31
what did you discuss on the day of the
collision with Eric Christensen in in
particular what what in particular
anything about the collision with Miss
Paltrow and my client Terry Sanderson a
relief that everybody was safe
and who was everybody everybody meaning
both people who collided
Miss Paltrow and Mr Sanderson yes
page 53
so just before the ski Collision please
describe what was happening had you all
met at the top of Flagstaff Mountain for
example yes we were we got off the
chairlift decided that we were going to
go down to lunch and can I interrupt
when you say we got off the chair Clift
who is we again just so we're clear
the Wii would have been Gwyneth apple
and I were on the chair lift I believe
that Eric was with Moses then we met up
with Brad and I cannot remember exactly
where the where his kids and their
instructors were they may have been down
already having the table for lunch so we
decided to go ski down bandana to the
Empire Lodge for lunch then as we
started skiing down bandana it was not
crowded at all there was really nobody
on the run and Moses and apple wanted
their mom to watch them you know wanted
to do this the the side of the run and
she could see she could see them ski so
we stopped to cross the run the Run was
clear there was nobody in front it was
it stands out in my mind because that's
a rarity bandana was fairly it was empty
where we were and so we had just crossed
the run and as I I mean as I looked
before we crossed the Run uphill there
was it was fairly there was really no
one in sight except farther up by a slow
sign from where we were and we crossed
made two turns and then I heard the
sound and looked over and that's when I
saw that they had collided and we were
both on the snow
what was the sound you heard
just I heard her voice and that's what
caught my attention
so I want to just go back over this
slowly these go to 56.
oh sorry
you inserted a word
inadvertently I apologize
then I heard the sound and looked over
and that's when
saw
that they had collided and were both on
the snow
go ahead and just read the rest of the
page that's fine
and what was the sound you heard just I
heard her voice and that's what caught
my attention
so I just want
to just go back over this slowly you
started skiing down bandana without
apple and Moses correct
still on 55. okay
you want to ask that one more time sure
so I want to just go back over this
slowly you started skiing down bandana
without apple and Moses correct and
gwenith and Eric correct
and you said you crossed the Run was
that near the top of the run near the
top of the Run
when you say you cross the Run does that
mean you went skiers left yes we were on
skiers right and then we had slowed down
or actually I believe we might have even
stopped enough that we were in a group
and then I looked up hill before we
crossed just to make sure it was safe
and then the kids and Eric and I crossed
the Run
to the left to the left to skiers left
and where Eric and you above apple and
Moses when you did this I was he was
behind he was above Hill and I was more
to the side and a little above Hill
and then what happened after you started
Crossing to the left we crossed to the
left and started skiing down the side
and then we heard after as I said two
maybe three times heard the sound of it
was more Gwyneth sounded surprised it
was like a surprise sound and you know
we looked over and they were both on the
ground
when you started to cross to the left
did Miss Paltrow then go straight down
to the right is that what she did she
stayed on the right but she did not go
straight
were you able to see her while you were
watching apple and Moses yes I was able
to see her how was she skiing she skis
small radius turns consistent speed at
this point in time it was slow because
she wanted to be able to see the kids
they were not skiing fast because the
kids are not fast
was she then going to stop and look up
or was she going to look to the left do
you know she was not going to stop
because we were skiing
okay is it your understanding Miss
Paltrow was going to look to the left
while she was skiing to her children's
skiing
no I cannot say what she was going to do
she was they were in her sight and we
were all the goal was to ski down to the
lodge for lunch
when did the topic of Miss Paltrow
watching her children come up
it
watching her children ski
when did the topic of Miss Paltrow
watching her children ski come up it was
mommy watch me and we want to go ski
this and she and so we we took them to
the side it wasn't a detailed plan on
how she was going to watch it was just a
plan to ski down to the lodge
okay and when Eric Moses apple and you
started skiing to the left was Miss
Paltrow skiing on the right correct she
was skiing on the right
page 68
was Miss Paltrow agitated she when she
was first getting up because she was
very surprised and shocked because that
was her comment was that that he hit her
what was her comment her comment was
that she was hit and was frustrated but
then as she got up and she then she
checked on him
he checked on her everybody was quite
calm nobody was agitated or yelling
when did she ski off Miss Paltrow I
don't recall exactly I believe she was
there for most of the time and yeah she
was there for most of the time I think
that when we had the verbal when it was
verbalized that everybody was okay Mr
Sanderson verbalized to us that he was
okay he was fine and that was his
response to her checking we checked ski
patrol checked and so then at that point
in time you know that's when she just we
said okay let's start we can start
disbursing because everyone expressed
and we were acting as if they were just
fine it was just a collision no harm no
foul
earlier you mentioned that Mr Sanderson
got up do you recall anyone helping him
get up
oh we were there both Eric and I were
there to help him I don't recall that he
he didn't need us to lift him off the
snow I don't recall needing to give much
assistance but we were there for both
parties to help them both and make sure
they were both okay to our abilities and
then assess him from then we would
assess if there was the need for ski
patrol to be called but they happened to
ski by and check themselves
page 71
and why didn't you write an incident
report that day I because nobody to our
knowledge nobody was hurt everybody left
the scene on their own volition and
their own everybody was able to leave
and it was again like just any other
incident where people you know got
tangled up and everybody was okay and
everybody left and so
page 82.
did Gwyneth Paltrow say she didn't see
Terry Sanderson before the Collision
she did not use that I mean he wasn't in
front of her so she he was not in front
of her but she didn't use that phrase
she said he hit me
you're assuming she was in front of him
correct I saw that there was nobody in
front of her when we were skiing and so
that that's not an assumption I there
was nobody on the hill with us in our
immediate vicinity
page 106.
Miss Oaks just before the Collision
Gwyneth Paltrow's children Moses and
apple wanted her to watch them skiing
correct yes we were skiing together down
the final run down to lunch
Miss Paltrow was skiing down to the
right looking up at her children to see
them skiing correct she was skiing down
on the right side her children were in
her periphery
one more time to what page we're on sure
now we're on page 107.
starting on line 14.
so she was looking over at the kids to
see them ski I can't say exactly where
she was looking they were in her
periphery she could see them while
looking ahead to ski
so miss Paltrow was distracted looking
at her children while she was skiing
just before the Collision
I would not say well I can't say that
she was distracted
was Miss Paltrow looking at her kids
while she was skiing down bandana run
when I saw her she was looking ahead at
the run in front of her was she also
looking at her children's skiing I did
not see her looking at her children
so miss Paltrow was distracted when the
Collision occurred looking at her
children correct
she's not looking at her children when I
saw her she was looking ahead skiing
down
so she wasn't watching her children is
that what you're saying yeah I didn't
they they were in her periphery I don't
know what she was looking at directly I
don't know that she was looking at them
directly she was looking ahead where she
was skiing when I saw her
at the moment of the Collision though
you had not seen her for three to five
seconds correct probably three to five
seconds
so you don't know where she was looking
other than she was supposed to be
looking at her children right
I don't know exactly where that she was
looking directly at them I do know that
when parents ski with their kids it
doesn't mean their eyes are glued on
their kids they can glance at them they
can see them in their periphery and as
long as the kids know the parents are
there and they're in their visual that's
what the kids want I don't know exactly
what she was doing the children were
satisfied
Moses and apple wanted their mother
Gwyneth Paltrow to watch them ski down
bandana correct
that's what they had said watch us ski
this Mom okay that was the conversation
page 111. okay and then maybe you
already answered this but in that when
you last Saw Miss Paltrow the three to
five seconds before the scream Did You
observe whether there was anyone below
her on the ski hill
I observed that the area in the front of
her was empty
I think that's it
111.
and that that's it okay thank you
they are the excused you may
right
Mr Owens you may call your next Witness
could we have a quick bench conference
here yes
nice
okay the parties have stipulated a fact
and it looks like it will save us some
time
um Mr Brad falchuk
who may or may not testify later
depending on how much time there is left
in the case the parties have stipulated
that he would testify where he worked
were he to be called as a witness that
he did not see the accident
is that correct from the plaintiffs yes
from the defense
did the court correctly
I believe so
um
he may or may not be called if there is
time thank you all right thank you and
you're and and so we'll now move to the
defendants have a deposition to read
yes we're going to try to get to the two
kids depositions first
no the March version Moses
so we're going to have a we're calling
Peter as a fake Moses to the stand okay
so Peter will read Moses
I don't think I have a marked copy
and I'd like the lawyers to each read
their side of the questioning so that we
can capture the minutes used by each
side I just need to get my copies back
that I gave to them what if we uh
because we don't have two more copies
because we're doing this on the fly but
if we have
we'll read Apple uh Moses all the marks
apart and you read Apple all the marks
that's fine let's do this
thank you
yes
oh that's right
that's right there they're not
copy you know what you better better
keep it
just in case
okay this is kind of weird but I'm the
questioner and you're Moses correct
do you recall how old you are at the
time
page seven
line 22. do you recall how old you are
you are were at the time nine okay I'm
turning the page
we're gonna back up because there's some
gray
could you just spell your name for the
record
okay so we we all stipulate this was is
Moses Martin
I'm on page seven
as you know we're talking about this ski
Collision that occurred about four and a
half years ago are you familiar with
that yeah
yeah and I'm gonna pick up where I was
do you recall how old you were at the
time nine
okay and you recall this ski trip in
February of 2016 correct yes about four
and a half years ago correct yes
okay you recall skiing that morning that
your mother was involved in this ski
Collision correct yes
I'm now turning the page to page nine
at the bottom
okay
when this ski Collision occurred do you
recall where you were at the moment the
ski Collision occurred
I do not recall where I was at the
moment it occurred
do you see the ski Collision I did not
see the actual Collision okay so let's
just start maybe at the beginning of the
run you got off a chair lift correct yes
and the run is called bandana are you
familiar with the bandana run yes
okay at the time of the Collision did
you or just
before the Collision occurred you were
skiing from the top is that correct yes
and who were you skiing with from what I
recall my instructor Eric
page 11. page 11 line 22 and you were
skiing with Eric as your ski instructor
just before the Collision correct yes
and do you recall who else was skiing
with you at that time no
was your sister am meaning Apple nearby
yeah
do you know where she was in relation to
you on the hill no
could she have been below you yes
you don't recall seeing your sister not
exactly
tell us what happened on the bandana run
just before the Collision what do you
recall
I recall skiing with my instructor and
briefly seeing the collision and then he
skied over and I followed him and I saw
my mother and a person behind her that
he had crashed who had crashed okay did
you hear a noise before the Collision no
and the person behind her was that a man
yes
yes moving to the top of page 13. was
this person uphill from your mother yes
how close were they your mother and this
other man as I recall decently close
let's just say you know this close you
know
see my hands they're about a foot about
14 inches apart or were they further
apart I think something like that but
I'm not 100 sure were they touching each
other I do not remember
was your mother was her head above her
skis so her head was uphill and her skis
were downhill yes
and the man that was nearby her
where his head in where was her his head
in relation to hers
or to his body was his head uphill or
downhill uphill
so I'm just gonna go back a little bit
so when did you first realize your mom
was involved in a collision how did you
realize that
realize the equipment
that realized that it was my mom so I
was standing around I realized that it
was my mother
and did you hear a noise that told you
there was something going on a commotion
or anything
when I skied over I heard my mom yelling
at the guy
what was she saying she was saying
something along the lines of what the f
word you just ran into me
and anything else that you recall at
that moment no was she standing up when
she said that I do not fully remember
but I believe she was on the ground
lying down okay did she get up by
herself I do not remember
I'm just going to go back in slow motion
to let's say three seconds before this
Collision occurred you were skiing with
Eric
if you're facing downward skiers left is
on the left side and skiers right is on
the right side
do you know which side you were on the
hill just before this Collision occurred
I was on the left
do you know how far on the left you were
no
do you think that
but Farish
okay
were you closer to the left edge of the
ski hill I believe so
and do you recall anyone else on the
hill at that moment I do not remember
were there other skiers on the hill yes
about how many I'm not
so what made you ski over to your mother
was it did someone tell you
I I was following my instructor but I
did not know what was going on
so you fall you followed your instructor
over to where your mother and this other
man were lying down correct yes
that scene you know your mother and this
man laying down what else what else do
you call
[Music]
then I remember my mom on the ground
downhill of of the man that was uphill
from her and I recall that they were
both on the ground at the time that I
skied over
about how far away do you think they
were I do not recall about a foot maybe
I'm asking how far apart your mother and
the man were when you skied over there
I'd say a foot maybe more were they
touching I do not remember and do you
remember your mother getting up yes but
not for a while
okay how long was a while like you know
five or ten seconds I'd say
and how did she get up
to get up by herself I do not remember
did someone help her I do not remember
do you recall large man
next to the ski Collision location I do
not remember
you said there were some other people
there what do you remember I remember
seeing a few people not a lot but maybe
three people not in including my
instructor
so there was your mother the man that
was involved in the collision and then
there was your instructor were there any
other people I
how many other people do you think I do
like was there one or two or three or
four maybe I do not recall and then what
did you do after you skied down to your
mother
I stood there wondering what was
then
I believe that afterwards we went to eat
lunch
I remember it
and who is we
um as I remember it was being me and my
instructor and I'm not sure whether my
mother came down afterwards or with us
so you skied down with your instructor
to the bottom yes of the hill to lunch
so you skied down the hill with your
instructor Eric Christensen yes anyone
else ski down with you I do not remember
just before the Collision your sister
was somewhere in the area skiing with
you I believe so anyone else in the area
I don't remember
did you recall Apple ski instructor no
do you recall her being present the ski
instructor for Apple I don't remember do
you remember Apple ski instructor's name
being Carrie Oaks Carrie
[Music]
so was anything said when you came down
to the Collision site where your mother
and this man were
my mother said to the guy what the f
word you just ran into me
and then anything else that you recall
not that I recall were people talking I
believe was the man talking I do not
really
remember when I say the man
I mean the man that was involved on the
ground
or the snow next to your mother I think
it should be on the snow next your
mother correct what do you when I say
the man next to your mother the person
that was involved in this key Collision
yes
so that's I do not I do not remember if
he was talking
okay do you remember if your ski
instructor Eric Christiansen was talking
I do I don't have a closer memory on
that no
did anyone beside your mother say that
they had seen the Collision
I do not remember
do you remember talking about the ski
collision at the bottom of the hill
what do you recall
my mother's saying that she got hit or
ran into
you said you went to lunch afterwards
correct yes did you discuss the ski
collision at lunch I believe so what do
you recall not much
who was at lunch with you after the ski
Collision
the day of the Collision have you talked
about the ski collision with anyone
anyone else you've talked to about the
ski Collision I don't
do you think you might have talked about
it with some other people
I don't remember
I'm now on page 25
when you ski down to the Collision site
before you left did you notice any ski
patrol or medical people come by I do
not recall
do you recall any other people in green
uniforms at the Collision site besides
your ski instructor I do not remember
before the ski Collision do you recall
saying something to the effect of hey
watch me ski no
have you ever said something like that
no
after the Collision this is bottom of
page 26 after the Collision when you
were watching your mom and this man on
the ground did Eric appear angry at all
not at all was he yelling raising his
voice shouting anything along those
lines no no not at all
why are you so sure it seems like your
memory is a little faded in some areas
which is okay and understandable but I
want to know why you're so sure about
this
how so what stands out to you he tried
to find out
and try and see how he could help
everyone without I was tried he tried to
help everybody get out of the situation
safely and yes
do you remember anything specifically he
said not specifically
I think plaintiff's council Lawrence
asked you some questions about they were
sort of vague about what
have you seen
said hey watch me ski maybe a better way
to put this question have you ever told
your mom hey Mom watch this before you
decide to do something on your skis
if you'd like her to watch you ski
I do not recall saying things along the
lines of that
did Eric help your mother stand up I did
not remember do you remember Eric
helping up the man that was involved in
the Collision I did not remember do you
remember skiing down with Eric after you
left the ski site I don't I don't know
if it was exactly Eric but I did ski
down alone I did not ski down alone
okay how close were you to Eric as you
skied down towards your mother
when you realized there was some
commotion or incident close I I skied
closely to him and then you stopped near
your mother yes and then how long after
you stopped did you ski down was it like
a minute or two I did not exactly
remember my best guess would be
somewhere along the lines of two or
three minutes
so you were standing there about two or
three minutes you think I think
I think that completes the questioning
your honor thank you
you may call your next Witness
uh
do you want to play Apple and you
they're going to read another deposition
of Apple
is that okay with you guys if they just
do it just let us know the pages because
remember I don't have fully marked copy
can you just spell your name for the
record please
oh sorry page 11.
line 13.
protected identity
and your last name
okay you understand that this is a
lawsuit involving a ski collision at
Deer Valley and on February 2000
February 26 2016. are you aware yeah
microphone more toward the center of the
two of you thank you
offline three
okay and do you recall this event back
in February 26
2016. yes
okay how old were you back in 2016 were
you
11 no 12. about 11 or 12. yeah yes
okay what were your skiing a bit what
was your skiing ability at the time
intermediate beginner okay
somewhere in between about how many
times have you skied approximately for
this date in February of 2016. four
times
page 15 line 10. okay and do you
remember your ski instructors on that
trip
yes we had Carrie Preston and then my
brother's instructor who I can't
remember the name of and one more female
instructor that I also cannot remember
the name of
page 16 line seven okay that morning do
you remember skiing with which
instructor Carrie
okay and your brother was skiing with
another male instructor I think you said
correct yes
I'll just represent you that his name is
probably Eric Christian Christensen does
that refresh your memory yes
17 first line
okay
so do you recall that the morning of
February 26 2016 when you were skiing
with Eric and apple or in Moses and
yes
Carrie where where had you been skiing
that morning before the incident with my
client
we were on the Mountain at the hotel and
that we were at it was a ski and ski out
type of thing we were mainly on the
greens and Blues
do you know about how many runs you had
skied before the incident
five or six I'd say and were you skiing
with Carrie that whole time yes was your
mother skiing with you at the same time
yes your mother ever skied different
runs when you were skiing with Carrie
I don't remember
okay your brother Moses about what level
is he is is he as a skier beginner
okay now I'd like to go to the bottom
before the ski Collision that subject to
this case Okay okay so you were at the
top of the ski hill and I've waved the
run as bandana do you recall the name of
the Run
yes it was bandana and why do you know
it was named bandana it was our favorite
run
page 19.
and you remember the ski run because
it's your favorite run correct it was
yes it was also the run you go down to
the hotel you were staying at you
next I'm going to ask you
what you recall happening on that run
but before do you recall the ski the ski
Collision
I did not see it but I recall the events
well what was going
for the ski Collision
we were on our way to lunch at the lodge
and who were you with
I was with my instructor my brother my
stepfather my mother my step-siblings
and their instructors
but we were all a bit scattered on the
run so some of us were in front others
were trailing behind a bit more and who
was with your group
I was ahead with my instructor my
stepsister and her instructor
was Brad falchuk with you no
sorry that's page 20.
so just to clarify at the time of the
Collision there was you Carrie Oaks your
ski instructor
there was a if and then there was if's
instructor who we don't know whose name
yet and then there was also your
brother's instructor Eric Christensen
and then there was your brother Moses
correct
yes but I was not with Moses and Eric
they were a little up the run I was all
I was closer to the lodge at the time
about how far away were you from your
brother Moses as your call before just
before the Collision
I would say I was
I don't really know how to say it I was
further down the Run they were in the
middle of the run I was towards the end
with my stepsister I was not with Moses
or my mother
did you know when the Collision occurred
not the exact time no did you hear
something before the Collision I don't
remember did you hear a scream I did
hear some commotion but I was further
down so I decided to continue to go down
to the lodge okay so when you heard the
commotion is that what you think is the
Collision yes
when you heard that commotion did you
look anywhere
I don't remember
Mother after you heard the commotion
again I don't remember so I'd like to
know just a just a couple seconds before
the collision and then the couple of
seconds after the Collision so only
about five seconds of time so you heard
in so you heard something a commotion
right yes and then you did and then did
you see anything
I don't recall if I had seen anything or
not I think that I did but I don't
remember okay and when you heard that
commotion you're with karaoke instructor
right yes
and where was she in relation to you was
she above you or below you I believe she
would have been in front of me that is
usually how we skied she would lead me
around 23 now
okay so the five seconds around the
commotion that you believe was the
Collision you were with Carrie Oaks and
if and then the three seconds afterwards
what did you do at that point
continue to ski down to life
and did you know at that time that there
was a ski Collision
when did you first learn that there was
a ski Collision
when my mom had arrived at lunch after
we had gotten there about five minutes
after and how did you learn about the
ski Collision my mom told me she
she was very
she told us what happened what did she
say
she said she came in and she immediately
I noticed that she looked a bit shocked
and I asked what had happened and she
said this a-hole ran into me he ran
right into my back
and I remember she did this motion
saying that he ran into her back and
they both went down
um but I I remembered that's what she
said
24. so let's go back to the moment of
the Collision or the commotion you heard
you heard the commotion you didn't see
the Collision but you continue to ski
down did yes did karaoke skew with you I
believe so yes and she skied with you
down to the bottom
down to where we were eating yes okay
and when I say the bottom I mean the
bottom of bandana run which is where The
Lodges and uh yes eating places are is
that clear yes
so after right after the commotion
karaoke's if and yusuke down to the
bottom of the bandana run correct yeah
and who is at the bottom of the run when
you got there
I don't remember I just know that we
were meeting everybody to eat okay at
the I'm sorry to keep going back to the
commotion did you see anyone else on the
ski run at the time of the commotion
well there were other people skiing but
again I don't really I didn't really pay
attention to what happened I just heard
um some sort of screaming going on above
me but I continued to ski down and I
don't remember if I turned around or not
okay did you recognize the screaming
whose voice What whose voice was it it
sounded like a woman but we were so far
down I didn't I couldn't really put
anything to it it wasn't very clear okay
how soon after you got to the bottom did
your mother arrive I would say five to
ten minutes
so you were waiting for her at the
bottom yes and what about Brad falchuk
was he with your mother when he arrived
at the bottom
I believe so did he arrive sooner than
she did
I don't remember well I'd like to go
back to the commotion and just let you
continue into and tell us to the best of
your memory what happened so you heard
that so you heard the commotion and then
what happened and then we continued to
ski down and we got to where we were
eating lunch we started to take off our
gear and then sat down and then shortly
after my mother Brad falchuk my brother
I can't remember if my stepbrother was
there or not but everybody else followed
in after I had arrived and who is
everybody else
to the best of my ability I'm pretty
sure it would have been my mother
my little brother Moses Brad falchuk
I would say one or two more instruction
instructors and my step-brother BF okay
do you recall which ski instructors were
there
again I remember
um Carrie my instructor Preston who
skied with BF and if
Eric and I believe that there was one
more female instructor but I can't fully
recall okay do you recall anyone else
besides the people you've mentioned at
the side of the commotion
no
we're on 27. so when you're at the
having lunch was the ski Collision
discussed at lunch yes and what do you
call about the that discussion my mom
was explaining what had happened saying
that a man ran into her back and they
both went down and she was in a State of
Shock and she decided after that she was
not going to ski for the rest of the day
which she never does she always stays on
but she decided to get off because she
was in shock and she was in a bit of
pain did karaoke say anything
I believe there was a conversation
between them I don't recall what it was
about but it was probably about my mom
getting off the mountain okay do you
recall anything else
I recall getting back onto the mountain
for a couple more runs and then I got
off the mountain and I think that my mom
was getting a massage okay when you got
back on the mountain after lunch who
were you skiing with I was skiing with
Carrie anyone else
um I don't remember maybe my stepsister
do you recall skiing with mm I does this
I don't remember okay were you concerned
about your mother at the time yes what
was your concern
well she
I never see her really like shaking up
like that and she was very clearly
visibly upset and she had some sort of
pain I can't remember what but she was
in a little bit of pain and I remember
that's why she went to the spa to get a
massage
the ski collision with anyone after you
left lunch I think that my step-siblings
and my brother and I we talked about it
because my brother was closer to the
collision and he had also said that he
skied into her back and they like both
went down together this Moses can you
tell us more specifically what Moses
said well Moses was Moses was kind of
telling us what had happened I don't
know if he for sure saw it but I know
that he was with people that saw it and
so they had told him what had happened
and
that it was what he said
my mom got hit in the back oh what did
he say again
he said that my mom got hit in the back
and their leg like she went they both
went down together after somebody had
skied into her into her back
we are on 30. okay when you finish
skiing did you discuss the ski Collision
yes with whom
I believe we talked about it at dinner
and after just I was checking in with my
mom to make sure that she was okay and
what did you discuss I asked her how she
was doing how she was feeling she said
she was in pain again I don't remember
where exactly but she did say that she
was in pain she had gotten a massage I
believe so this was around dinner time
and we had just kind of gone over what
had happened did she say anything about
my client Terry Sanderson
she had earlier in the day immediately
not immediately after but after five
minutes after we all met at lunch she
said that he had skied into her back and
she called him an a-hole who had skied
into her back anything else you can
recall I remember she was very frantic
about it so she probably said something
along the lines of that but that would
be all that I remember to the best of my
ability 31. okay when you discussed it
with your mother and you said she was
frantic what do you mean by that
she was in a State of Shock she was just
she was very upset and she was in pain
since that collision had you have you
seen your mother in that State of Shock
like that since that not no not like
that she under so you discussed the ski
Collision that night at dinner and do
you recall you were staying at a a hotel
suite or something
yes we were in a hotel
the next day do you recall what you did
I believe we skied in the morning I
can't remember if we had left that day
or not I the next day
I don't I don't really remember much
33. and do you recall how many ski
instructors were with you at the time of
the Collision when you started skiing
again I believe either three or four
and one was Carrie yes and one was Eric
Christensen yes
was another one Preston yes was there
anyone else you that you recall
I believe that there was one more person
but I I can't be too sure about that
okay did anyone tell you they had seen
the Collision
I don't think so no other than your
mother no
35 okay earlier earlier I think that you
said Moses and said other people had
definitely seen the Collision do you
recall saying something like that
I don't think that I said I don't think
that I said that what do you recall
Moses saying I remember him sort of
telling what happened I don't know that
he was I don't know if he saw it or not
like saw the actual Collision but I know
that he saw my mom on the floor
um I believe I said that he saw my
um I believe I said that he saw my mom
on the floor but I don't think that he
saw the actual Collision okay so after
the commotion or Collision you you skied
down to the bottom of bandana around
correct yes but again I I personally
didn't see the Collision okay but you
heard this commotion yes
someone say to you ski down to the
bottom after the hit of the Hill after
the commotion no we did not think
anything of it we continued to ski down
I don't even know if we stopped the we
included includes carry out yes
did anyone ask you to wait by the side
of the Hill after the commotion no I
don't remember that we
I don't I don't know
that you recall do you recall seeing
anyone going to to help your mother
after the commotion
I again did not see the aftermath I had
continued to ski down but I believe that
people did help her and what makes you
believe that because I assumed that she
would have needed help up and she was
close to her boyfriend Brad who is now
her husband at the time and both my
brother's ski instructors and I believe
BF ski instructor so I'm assuming that
they would have helped her but karaoke
stayed with you down to the bottom of
the skied with you stayed with you down
the bottom of the hill yes what about
Eric Christensen
do you recall what he was doing after
the
I believe that he was with my brother
who was near my mom
so he was near the Collision
okay and do you recall which side of the
Hill you were on let's talk about skiers
left and right that means that if you're
skiing downhill the left would be the
skier facing downhill to their left
the same on the right do you do you know
which side of the Hill you were on ski I
don't I don't remember okay do you think
he might have been in the middle of the
hill or the side or the near the edge of
the Run bandana I don't remember
can you be sure exactly that Carrie Oaks
didn't stop and help your mom after the
question or do you remember that at all
I don't remember I'm I think that we
were further down because I know that we
got to lunch first so I don't I don't
remember okay
I don't think so
do you recall before the commotional
bandana run saying something to the
effect of hey watch us ski down the hill
no do you recall if Moses said something
like that no do you recall if any of
your other people in your group like if
or BF say something like that I don't
know okay I'm just going to show you
something here real quick do you
recognize the person on the left there
that's scary that's that's Carrie Oaks
yes
42. so Carrie Oaks was recently deposed
apple and she actually has specific
memories of being on the scene of the
Collision would you defer to her
testimony of specific memories rather
than sort of your vague memory that she
has with you
yes I could have easily been with
another instructor I believe iaf had an
instructor
Lawrence I think we have a picture of
Eric can he
which has a picture of him on the cover
of it he looks a little older than he
did
oh he's isn't he the one oh my God I
remember him so well he was the best
oh my God he was the best he just
he would give us can candies and he
would tell us
yes that's Eric would you say he was
under 50 years old I don't remember
I never really skied with him so I never
really saw his face
that's the end of it judge
we're ready willing and able to testify
in person on Monday morning
before we address that after I excused
the jury
okay
we're going to I'm going to excuse you
now until tomorrow morning at nine
o'clock I will recess please do not
discuss this case with anyone including
other jurors please do not attempt to
learn anything about the case outside of
the courtroom including from other
jurors please avoid radio TV internet
and newspaper reports on this case
please keep an open mind throughout the
presentation of the evidence and finally
please do not form or Express an opinion
on the case until such time as it is
finally submitted to you for
deliberations
have a good evening
okay Mr Owens what was it that you
wanted to put on the record
I would always prefer live testimony to
reading transcripts but the kids were
not available
and uh
mostly I just want to put that on the
record I was expecting to take over the
case on Monday morning given multiple
assurances that I could do so and I was
not able to do so
the multiple assurances were if we're
done and we intended to be done it
sounds like some kind of a
statement that we didn't do something
we're supposed to do and they took
almost as much time cross-examining more
on some of these Witnesses and that's
why we didn't finish
you could have called them live if you
still can call them live
but I understand that you wanted to put
that on the record so thank you
unavailable
all right
um so we're going to take a short recess
maybe five minutes and come back and
work on jury instructions is that right
okay just take a quick bathroom break
and we'll be right back and hopefully
we'll wrap it up by the end by half past
the hour
nine what time would you like everybody
here
845 be ready to go because once all the
jurors are assembled we can start
perfect
defendant Elaine
no
plaintiff's objections to defendant
Paltrow's non-stipulated jury
instructions
the nature of the case we already
resolved on page four
okay sure
I'm working off the one that was filed
okay you're you're filing which is your
your objection
it is
I can give you the docket number
plaintiff's objections is docket number
are you with me on the defense side
yeah we're only looking at our
documentary looking at their document
because it contains their written
objection
so starting on I'm on page six
defendants instruction number nine
the
foreign
are you are you with it
or are you there
okay what page is not uh it's seven
page number six fault defined
so this this is the Fault definition
is there any reason why we don't just
use the fault jury instruction from the
model Utah jury instructions I I see
that I guess both of you started with
that but why not stick with it
Mr Egan
okay
all right
I'm looking at CV 201 on the model Utah
jury instruction second edition
oh
your honor we have it and your question
was why not use the model instruction
why not stick with CV 201
I think
um
if I'm recalling this correctly and it's
been a bit we were thinking that the
model construction
doesn't uh incorporate the counter claim
so we wanted to just make sure that it
was clear that there needed to be a
decision about fault for both parties
okay that's what I that's what I recall
off the top of my head your honor
so if I'm remembering correctly it was
kind of that second sentence where we
say You must also decide whether Gwyneth
Paltrow is harmed and if so whether
anyone is at fault for that harm okay
and the the uh there's also an objection
to adding the word skiing in the second
paragraph
just negligence rather than negligent
skiing because I think their claim is a
little broader than just negligent
skiing
I see because of the post Collision
claim right
um I mean I suppose Loosely it's skiing
because it's part of the skier code of
conduct
right to do after an accident but right
yeah to me I guess that's I don't know
that
that makes a huge difference to the jury
if they see skiing I think they'll
understand that it's the whole
part of negligence
can you still argue your case if it just
reads what the jury instruction does and
this the fail wrongful actor failure to
act alleged in this case is negligence
your honor
generic negligence is used in all sorts
of things from skiing to Autos yeah
you've got that in your brief in your in
your objection
sure I mean I I don't know
can you still argue what you need to
argue yes
yes I could
um well this this goes to a little bit
of trial strategy is plaintiff resting
this will help me argue this very issue
they haven't rested yet because you
haven't finished your cross of their
client so
um sorry if I don't know this but if I
say I'm done with my cross
I'm going to call Terry in my case I can
still use leading questions man may I
sure he's an adverse party yes so yes so
if I agree to give up my cross of Terry
they they are agreeing to rest first
thing in the morning
this is not where this is here we're
talking about jury instruction I I
actually this affects my first of all
I'm entitled to know if they're resting
where the judge ruled your honor rule
that we would know each day's lineup the
following day
I think they
they benefit from just having this open
case because it's just this one other
witness and then it's no now it's two
now it's three and uh I want them to
rest well if you if you'll decide
whether you're done questioning Mr
Sanderson I hear what I decide pardon I
hereby decide that I am done so do you
have any more evidence to put on
well we don't we weren't prepared to
talk about that two of our team are
obviously not here with us right now if
we can get on the phone with them we
could discuss that and come up with a
with whether we are going to put
anything okay
I mean we're here I mean as I understood
it that was the only that's what I
understand too but okay
and when you just step out and verify
that while we continue okay thank you
so would you like to come back to this
one then after you get that answer yes I
intend well I intend to file a motion
for directed verdict on the issue of
post post-collision negligence
but what I didn't hear that Steve
on post-collision negligence are you
gonna file something on it well are you
just going to make it
depends how much work we have tonight
okay all right well as to this okay so
then well it would be my inclination
just to
use the word negligence anyway and you
can and if it ends up that it's only the
the before and to the Collision that's
at issue then you can certainly argue
that to the jury
okay for emotions granted I I would want
that tweaked because I don't want them
to be confused that there's a
post-collision issue it's only the
scheme sure if there's a directed
verdict on the post-collision issue I
think there should be some clarification
thank you we agree if if our direct
adverting point one sure okay so in the
meantime then
um that's I mean that's the instruction
as it will stand and if if the landscape
changes you can certainly ask for an
additional instruction or a modification
okay
turning then to instruction defendants
instruction 12 on allocation of fault
is this also Mr Egan in order to well
you've already come to an agreement it
says here so that one's okayed
right
yeah it looks like that's number 12.
number 13 inherent risk of skiing
um I
I think you've already well what's your
you would like the uh an inherent risk
to of skiing instruction and the
plaintiffs don't want an inherent risk
of skiing instruction is that right Mr
Bueller correct for the reason stated
could you just tell me again why it is
that you believe you should have one and
have you have you evaluated the uh
wasn't there a case that had three
factors in it somewhere on whether a
stat was it Dutton that whether a
statute
creates
[Music]
whether a statute should be used
in other words it talks about the
protected class that's being that's
designed
to to protect
all looking at that your honor I I also
I'm struggling to remember the
particular name I
that may be correct and Donovan I
believe is uh
it doesn't it didn't go into a
significant analysis of that because it
decided not to
uh the court decided it didn't need to
rule on that point if I'm remembering
correctly and so it just decided I think
these other cases that you mentioned
and I can look and see if I can find and
I quickly I have Donovan can I read one
sentence from it your honor sure
to be clear we do not establish a
categorical rule that an inadvertent
Fall by itself
can never establish negligence
and we overturn Richie Ricci to the
extent that it established such a rule
I don't I don't know if that's helpful
but the way my work mind works is that
means
uh
Falls can occur despite appropriate care
and that's that's obvious
okay I know where that's coming from I
actually marked that here so
anything else you want to add to your
counter to the objection yes it is the
law I mean uh it doesn't say when it
says you are
assuming the risk of collision with
other skiers
um that is a legislative finding that's
not unique to a ski resorts I think it's
just a statement of Law and skiing has
inherent risks
okay
anything else on that one I'm gonna I'm
gonna take that under advisement
okay
yeah to update you're on and I
understand that as I stepped out to make
the phone call
they then defense said they would not be
calling Terry Sanderson again correct is
that correct
we don't have any objection to resting
right now okay so so the the plaintiff
at this point is resting
and I can certainly we can certainly do
it officially in front of the jury so
that they can see that you're resting
but sure but does that resolve your
issues Mr Owens going forward yeah
okay
you're honor in case it's helpful and
you may have already beat me to this but
it looks like colossimo was the case
that they were citing yes yes so yeah
looks like sounds like you beat me to it
and I read the what what they were
citing as well and I'll continue to
consider that
sure
even though my name's on this Donovan
case it was Judge Pettit that made that
ruling
I think I had it I think I had the case
in case it came back
all right I found the inherent risk of
skiing statute
78b4 402-1
it does say inherent risk of skiing
meaning the dangers or conditions that
are
an integral part of the sport of
recreational competitive
or professional skiing include
that lists a number of things
and one of them under sub section F
collisions with other speakers or skiers
that is a legislative
finding
78 B 4 402
sub f
now I didn't read it word for word your
honor but I changing weather conditions
are not part of our case various
variations in terrain are not part of
our case so I went straight to f
and then how how would you respond to
the very that same statute that says
that that definition of inherent risk of
skiing is is as used in this part
yes
how would you how would you how do you
look at that
seems as though they're defining the
term for this statute
foreign
is to protect ski resorts
but uh
it doesn't say anywhere like this does
not
uh provide
any defenses or skiers and so
the wording
works with skiers and skiers
if I don't
approve this requested instruction it
doesn't mean that you can't argue that
it just means that there will not be a
legal instruction and I haven't decided
yet but you certainly can argue that
there are inherent risks of skiing and
you can talk about what those are and
you can you know as they're Tethered to
the facts of this case
that's that's fair game it's fair game
I appreciate it they just won't know
it's the law it is
true and it should come the law should
come from the court correct
and if
that's my decision does
uh does the statutory definition of
inherent risk of skiing
contained in 78b 4402 does that apply to
a skier on skier Collision liability
Mr Bueller oh just if the court changes
its mind or considers data mind yeah we
would like another opportunity to
discuss it but it doesn't have to be
done tonight well I I need to know now
what your arguments are so I can fully
evaluate this we would say your honor it
does not apply to skier on skier that
the main thrust of this as defense
conceded concedes excuse me is uh is to
indemnify ski resorts for accidents that
take place upon their mountains and not
for skier on skier liability that's
always going to be available
okay
thank you so I'll take that one under
advisement number 13.
next number 14 this is the one I was
talking about earlier uh
why not use
the
um yeah the violation of safety law
cv212
do you have that handy
standard Utah jury instruction whenever
there's a an allegation of an ordinance
or a law a legislative enactment that
creates a duty
or
is a safety law
we're fine without your honor okay
I'm sorry I just I had it and then I
lost it he gave me the number one more
time
cb212 one two
thank you
and then you take the the actual quote
from the ordinance and put it in there
the language from the ordinance itself
do I have a copy of the ordinance
you should I think we might have it as
an exhibit we can provide that could you
email that to my clerk well
because they've arrested
so we shouldn't be doing new things that
haven't come into evidence there was a
witness that referenced the ordinance
right I'm not sure
and this is this is law
that that document is a safety law I
don't know that any
any witness so testified
came up with
at least one other witness that I recall
I don't recall which one specifically
right now
I don't believe
it's in a plaintiff's exhibit 38.
what's plaintiff's exhibit 38 yeah it's
the uh
Reckless scheme ordinance of the summit
okay so plaintiff's exhibit 38 yeah
that was not admitted correct
was that one admitted
the one they objected to but we would
we don't you know we wanted to admit it
so it and and it wouldn't be appropriate
I don't think to give the whole
ordinance to the hand it to the jury or
maybe it is but this is the place where
that law should should lie
and there was a witness that referenced
the ordinance
like this is a safety law
to see the ordinance but if it what is
is this basically it skiers have a duty
to avoid Reckless or negligent skiing
bugger mentions it
but in our objections I believe we have
quoted the ordinance in case that's
helpful on page seven
um
okay I think I understand arguments on
that I'll take it anyway
there's been no and this will be the
subject of a directed verdict now that
we know they're closed
uh there's been no comment that
there's a violation of the
post-collision that there's a
post-collision negligence or that it
caused any harm and let me emphasize
that for a minute
the
um
breach of a negligence Duty and to also
show that it caused harm
by all accounts
well I should say by Ramon's account he
notified them
of the person who they say injured him
and Mr
Sanderson that evening texted I'm famous
he said that because he knew who he who
he had collided with
so
I believe that whole post Collision
negligence claim there's insufficient
evidence both on
breach of that Duty and on
causation of damages
let me address it when you make your
motion okay
defendants instruction 24 on spoliation
is what's the defendant's response to
their objection
thanks your honor and as I understand
your order and this is important for the
plaintiffs on closing
the court has precluded either party
from commenting on it uh on how this
arose so for instance I don't believe it
would be fair for plaintiffs to say hey
Mr Owens an opening so that link is
really important and here it is
I wanted the court the jury to be
advised that uh it came through my
office uh the the member of the public I
identified it was able to open it and
the court declined that which is fine
but I don't want to be beat over the
head with it now to the spoiliation
issue
the GoPro is separate from the link
the GoPro came from a telephone call Mr
Sanderson made to his wife excuse me his
daughter
Shea who testified
she got off the phone with him
believing there was a GoPro video and
she typed it to her dad I can't believe
this is all on GoPro
plans
have denied there was ever a GoPro
I think everyone agrees that if there
were a GoPro video of the incident that
would be the very best evidence
I believe the defense has made a
sufficient showing
that there's a possibility that there
was a GoPro video and it was deleted and
that we are entitled to the adverse
reference adverse inference
uh if the jury were to find the GoPro
was deleted
that that's as if I find which means
the judge
so I don't think it quite works
and what do you mean isn't the wording
of the Muji spoilation one oh that's
that's what you guys used yeah I have
found I have determined thank you I
don't have it in front of me
so it doesn't seem to work right so Mr
Bueller or I'm not sure who's arguing
this Mr Sorensen I think that there is
sufficient evidence in front of the jury
from which they could decide that there
was a GoPro video and so I think and and
that it was in your uh that your client
had access to it so I I am inclined to
consider a spoliation instruction but
not as it's currently written I think it
would have to be a permissive
instruction in other words if you find
that there was a GoPro and if you find
that it was destroyed then you may
uh you may decide that it contained
information that was adverse to the
plaintiff's case
in other words it's not prescriptive
it's not requiring them to make that
finding they just can make that finding
because there's different levels of
spoliation instructions and I think
that's probably the least stringent
and as we understand it you're honor I
think spoliation is a legal issue that
you are are supposed to determine and so
I don't know that it's a factual
determination for a jury to find whether
or not there was spoliation
if I think there is in this I mean I
think in this case
a legal instruction could be crafted
that would allow them to make factual
findings and apply it
is and and is that as we understand it
the factual findings are just Shay's
written email that's those are the facts
that would support so far a finding
right
but there's no intent there's not been
any evidence to this point of any
intentional destruction of that evidence
or yeah there's a
there's a Utah case that says that you
don't that a party doesn't have to show
that it was intentionally destroyed just
that it the language the language in the
Muji says that but there's a Utah case
let me see if I can find it
so I guess turning to the defendants I'm
looking for a diff I mean I I can't
approve the instruction as it's written
so so it's denied as it's written do you
have the case that you're I'm looking
right now yeah hold on I mean Muji lists
three cases I think
instructions
I'm not on my normal computer and this
doesn't have all the software that mine
does
all right let's see
though I don't have it
here
I think it's highly prejudicial to
them without you know
a shred I mean I guess the daughters
I can't believe
there's a GoPro
of
I understand
so that was denied as written
so who's
is the burden on us to now we want the
instruction I need one that's consistent
with the law and the facts of this case
along the lines that I just outlined
case that it'd be a permissive
instruction James or Peter can I
delegate this to you
so a jury instruction that's consistent
with the law and the facts of this case
right and this and the specific wording
you don't like
so this wording no because it doesn't
require well right but the jury has to
do the jury has to determine the number
three things one that had existed
two that it was available to the
plaintiffs and not the defendants which
I guess the evidence
you know that is available to the
plaintiffs
and then thirdly that um
I have destroyed it yeah that yeah the
plaintiff destroyed it
can we argue and then the last part of
that is if they make those findings and
and I'd like to see the authority if you
could take a look Peter for the
authority that I'm referring to if they
make those findings then they they they
may but they're not required
to uh
assume that it would have been negative
from the plaintiff's case
I'm not using probably the best
terminology but you get the idea
can we then argue against that sure
absolutely you can bring up evidence
absolutely exfoliation could have been
the ski patrol or Deer Valley because
Deer Valley I know our client thought
that he asked me before we even took
this case he asked well don't they have
surveillance cameras there and I said no
a lot of resorts don't and Deer Valley
didn't at the time well they do that
evidence isn't before the jury it has
your argument has to have some thread to
the evidence
are we okay but but you can but when you
whenever whatever this instruction ends
up being you can certainly argue the
facts as to the different elements that
are in this instruction
okay I will wait for it as well
so instruction 28 introduction of tort
damages
the objection is that it's
should be should be changed because
they're not they're not asking for
economic damage is that right
yes and I think we gave a counter
instruction down below your honor on
that on page 16.
that
are you okay with the counter
instruction
okay page 16 may I read it for one
second yeah sure
so I would prefer uh
if something's simpler and more accurate
I would prefer just say
rather than you must decide how much
will fairly compensate her we just uh if
I I hope I'm following your brain track
here
Paul throws uh has agreed that it's just
one dollar is that the issue we're
addressing whether to do this big
generic
conversation about
Gwyneth damages yeah it's just following
the Muji and there's some changes I
think we should change Muji just because
it's simpler and to the facts just to
say one dollar
rather than you must find I guess they
could decide they only want to give her
25 cents but
um
I don't I think it's confusing to the
jury
it's sort of like uh if we stipulated
that they have three hundred thousand
dollars in medical bills
we should just say we have stipulated
that there are three thousand dollars in
medical three hundred thousand dollars
in medical bills we wouldn't say we
think you should decide so I understand
that that you want to simplify it is it
is it an incorrect statement of the law
I guess is my question
is it word for word Muji
Sorenson
I don't
I don't have the reference below sorry
it's been a number of weeks since we
crafted this
record all right well I understand both
parties position on that moving on to 29
is there anything you want to respond to
on their objections there
they object to the use of the one dollar
amount as previously stated
and they're seeing they're asking for a
compromise there
I'm reading it
okay I'm looking at the top of 17 and
that's their oh that's yours the bottom
of 17 is what they're proposing thank
you for orienting me
so same issue one dollar
uh where are we making them think about
Miss Paul throws a number of economic
damages they brought in the fact that
there's a jury there's uh potential
lawyer fees involved
and we don't want them speculating about
that
so Ms Paltrow is seeking economic
damages on the verdict for him uh do you
want to just put one dollar in her blank
so that if they get to a yes
I mean how do you want to deal with the
one dollar claim or do you want to leave
it open so they might award more
um that's the person defending that is
Kristen Van Orman or oh that's true
that's true and uh
I don't feel comfortable okay
so what if they came back we want to
give everyone their your
what we we defer to what we've
there for the special okay all right so
the confusion I think your honor what if
they came back and said we want to give
Gwyneth one million dollars
all right we've sort of set them up that
they have the power
when they don't uh to order more than
one million one dollar
and and then it just sets us all up for
potential problems right
I understand
I will take that under advisement number
pre-existing conditions
there is a emoji on this and the court
would
just follow the Muji
I think it's an issue for us your honor
of the 2018 Muji or the current Muji we
prefer the 2018 Muji but
is that the second
Muji second the most recent
I think ours follows more along with
lines of the 18 so the not the set not
the current but
the previous Muji
okay so they it looks like the only
thing that they object to Mr Owens is
the if any
that's bolded and highlighted on page
18.
is that is that right
I don't have the old set I mean
I would go for with the new the new Muji
as the current state of the law which
lie I don't like but it is the state of
the law
what would you object if any on there
yeah there's no if any in Muji 2018 CV
2018.
so so I'll just follow the Muji on that
34. I mean you can certainly make that
argument I think we've stipulated to 34
your honor okay 34 stipulated
45 Hit and Run
I think I've already addressed that when
we say stipulated was it a modification
no that's modified well I don't know if
it was a modification or not the problem
was we had agreed to some of these
before they actually were filed with
with James and we had gone back and
forth and so this was one that was
listed as sort of being in disagreement
but we had actually previously
stipulated so so at the top of page 20
that's the defendant's proposed
instruction on mitigation and the
plaintiff agrees to it
okay
is that right yes yeah that's the top of
Mister and I should put on the record Mr
Egan had to leave because we have four
experts staying at a hotel right now
okay prepare for tomorrow okay
uh defendants instruction 45 hit and run
I think I've already covered that it was
yeah it's been requested and denied
for the reason stated earlier
46 I've already given the demonstrative
which
big
instructions
um
I I did give the instruction again and I
verbally inserted the word animation
uh
I suppose I could take and and modify
the jury instruction that was already
given and substituted for the one that
they received at the beginning of the
case that contains the word animation I
think that's fine
Mr Owens I think I heard you correctly
basically take the jury instruction that
I gave the the jury orally and
um
and take the one that was read at the in
the opening on demonstrative exhibits
and change and add animations to it so
that we can substitute it in their
package and animations yeah yes we have
other
demonstratives that are not animations
right I think you could and it won't it
won't exclude those it'll still contain
the language and the Muji of charts and
summaries
chart summaries including animations
I think I already covered 47 I think
there was an instruction on there is in
the opening instructions there's already
an instruction on Deer Valley Resorts
dismissal
may I comment on the animations briefly
sure your honor we had 7 22nd animations
uh not all have come in
I wanted them all in
your honor ruled that that was
duplicative or uh
I thought maybe that was the word you
use but while we had Eric Christiansen
on the Christensen on the stand
and then uh our expert
Dr Bogger was not permitted to talk
about the animations so uh and I think
our Witnesses tomorrow we're not going
to be able to probably get the
animations in through them so I think we
were prejudiced by this uh kind of being
cut off having to
formally go through every step because
the playoffs wouldn't agree to anything
and then
so I I do feel like the defense was
prejudiced in not being able to
introduce all of their animations
through the expert or excuse me through
Eric Christensen
in our
Mr Bogger today
so I'm just putting that objection on
the record if there's a way
for me to
mitigate that I'm happy I'm all ears to
get the animations all all in
yeah
I'm not going to tell you how to do your
job
I would like you to
well they were they were duplicative
they were becoming I mean the three were
were fine but additional ones were
duplicative as to that witness's
testimony and at the pre-trial order on
all of these animations I thought laid
out what needed to happen in order to
get them in
okay I'm just putting that on the record
I think they each added a little bit
different viewpoint
they were done by different views but
we can proceed okay instruction 48 this
is tied in
with your your Mo your directed verdict
motion so I'm going to leave that in
advance right now
on the post accidentals negligence claim
thank you you are
so I think that covers all of those
things
yeah can we inform a record in the
parties
that we intend to call Dr Bain via
Zoom for his trial testimony we'd like
to get that pre-approved before we go
through the great expense and
preparation of having them at 9am on
Thursday the 30th
that's rebuttal as rebuttal one hour
do you have a sense when you're going to
rest your
your case
no but let's look to the time frame
I'm going to tell you my latest thoughts
and I can tell you that they change
hourly
no we've mentioned this uh many times
before you know let me think for a
minute here we mentioned it earlier
yeah I know you did hours ago and my
response is the same as it has been for
the defendants when they rest your case
you can put on your rebuttal
and I realized that that puts you in a
difficult position with an expert that
may not be available and we certainly
want to make any accommodation that we
can but as the plaintiffs were entitled
to put on their case uninterrupted
except by whatever exceptions you guys
agreed on I think the defense has the
same right
all right so as I understand that's fair
your owner thank you
I'm reading this document and I'm trying
to interpret it this is the Court's time
keeping yeah thanks
because
I'm thinking aloud uh but I I am trying
to be responsive to your question when
do you think I'm gonna rest
all right so as I read this both play
both sides have had roughly the same
amount of time 15 hours
both sides have about nine hours
total
so four and a half hours each isn't it
more like eight hours
remaining
let's see I'm looking at
five tomorrow and 40 hours total and
about
30.4 are done
I think I think you have to look at it a
little differently I should yeah just
what's available tomorrow and what's
available on Thursday
okay so it's hopefully we'll get five
and a half hours in front of the jury
tomorrow and two and three quarter hours
in front of the jury on Thursday so that
was is what you got left to split and
that is not for closing arguments yeah
it is oh that includes yep otherwise
we're giving closing arguments in the
afternoon on Thursday
yeah I could agree with that you know I
mean I'm fine yeah otherwise that's what
we're doing maybe we bleed into the
afternoon a little bit
um if we have unforeseen things pop up
but that would be my hope
you're honored just
like
I want to help Council understand that
he may only have
three hours and
or 95 minutes tomorrow or something
three hours in
50 minutes tomorrow is that the way how
I interpret this because it's
7.75 hours left remaining well I don't
know that's just an estimate
but yes
so his experts in his case has less than
four hours 5.3
7.7.5 out seven and a half hours
plus 45 that's 8 hours and 15 minutes if
everything goes great
that's left to be in front of the jury
I wonder if the distinction
so this last 45 minutes we agreed not to
count toward anyone does that
uh is that
was that counter recognize the eight
versus
okay
in which which side was it added were
they added to
but will you will you give me the new
numbers not including it in other words
take that out of the defense
can you give that to me
can you give me new numbers and then
I'll put them on the spreadsheets
okay so that changes that changes
Dynamic by 33 minutes
it's good by the way you're keeping us
on track
um
I heard you today say strictly held to
this and then I heard you say earlier I
think like
in an Ideal World I may have misquoted
you
so are we like to the minute on this
um oh I could just tell you what's
happened in the past in the past
um one party has gotten to the end of
their case and they haven't used up half
the time and they say we're done you
know the the other side can use the rest
of our time if they need it
I've had that scenario and then but I've
also had a scenario when
um
when they've gotten to the end of their
time and they're asking for more time
and it it's not on the books where it
would be available and they had to sit
down
mid-question
I don't want to do that I mean and that
that was an unusual case where well I'm
not going to go into the details but I
don't want to do that so a natural a
natural stopping point
uh close to the time that you're
entitled so in other words when you get
down to five minutes I'll let you know
and you should wrap it up and if you go
over 30 seconds or a minute or depending
on the questioning that's going on with
the witness or in this case you'll
probably be in your closing arguments
right
yeah under this plan
um you'll be I will be giving you be
giving you five minute warning while
you're in your closing arguments
and uh
this includes their rebuttal time yes
and if we go over we don't get a closing
argument right
your honor uh one other question
I mean I'm not making a pre-judgment
here but if I apply the rules strictly
yes when your time and half your time is
gone if you haven't given a closing
argument or you're not done with your
closing argument
theoretically you'd be cut off at that
point
I don't want to have to make that
decision or I don't want to have to cut
you off
so I'm hoping that you'll figure it out
it's nice that we're even talking about
like how to do closing argument that
means our trial is coming to a close
which is lovely
um One Way James Egan and I have split
the case up is I focused on liability
and he's focused on Damages uh
is there any objection if we choose to
bifurcate those issues in our closing
arguments in the past when I've been
asked that I've allowed it as long as
they do truly bifurcate between damages
and liability
and you guys can do that too
and their rebuttal on closing is also
included in their time it is
as much as I whine about this I actually
kind of like it
can the parties let's say at the end of
the day tomorrow
stipulate that each side can have 30
more minutes
we'll take that under consideration I'm
not offering it yeah I'm not offering it
I'll consider it I'm wondering if
because I want to consider that I need
to consider the jury you know and when
they'll start to deliberate
but I'll certainly consider it if you
guys do that I mean if if the evidence
closes tomorrow then you've got two
hours and and two and three quarter
hours to give your closing arguments
well
maybe I would want to call the jury back
at 8 30 so I could read them the closing
instruct closing instructions and then
they would start then you would start
your closings at nine o'clock
and you'd each have
half of that time
to allocate between the plaintiff's
argument the defendant's response and
then the any rebuttal
so I I know I'm just telling everyone I
want an hour for closing so I'm just
sort of building that in I think
plaintiff said they wanted an hour for
closing
so
just kind of knowing that's the thing
then uh
okay can I give my lineup for tomorrow
yes so Dr Black is a radiologist
Dr Hesh
h-o-e-s-c-h is a neurologist
Dr eastvold is a neuropsychologist Dr
askanazi is a neuropsychologist
potential remaining Witnesses if we get
to them would be Dr Sanderson
Brad falchuk
Jenny Sanderson
potentially Gwyneth Paltrow
I think we're going to run out of time
but are you going to rest tomorrow do
you think
so I think it'll depend on the time
okay
we'll have to watch it then okay
pathetical your honor
if they rest is it possible for it
to go to the jury sooner or we just
no because we go to the jury Thursday
we'll need to resolve the most directed
verdict motions as well as the
jury instructions themselves but and
we'll need tomorrow evening to do that
and but the jury could be dismissed yes
early tomorrow yeah Thursday
you can guarantee we are taking our full
day tomorrow I mean
but
I guess I should say Never Say Never but
in terms of our timings so in terms of
the Court Personnel I need to move on to
get to the other other instructions I'm
looking at Paltrow's objections to
plaintiff's jury instructions starting
on page four do you have the docket
number your honor
council do you have to know your doctor
and I think the special verdict form is
going to be pretty straightforward I
think the plane of special verdict form
most closely follows the Muji special
verdict form and I think it's perfect
for this case so I will
thank you I don't think we need to talk
about it today but that's essentially
What will what will be put together I
don't think it they don't differ that
much
man look at it uh when when the courts
printed it out may I look at it one last
time
of course this is what we're giving and
then yeah okay thank you yeah you'll
have a copy
and I'll read it to the jury as well so
you'll have we'll go through it all
together before the jury before you
start your closing argument so 9 16 9
did you find that we did okay
so page four nature of the case is
already resolved stipulated facts
um
that wasn't really or hasn't hasn't been
a stipulation other than the fact that
we did today if you want to put that in
jury instruction we can certainly do
that otherwise I've read it to the jury
fault we already covered fault
your honor what was that last one you
said the stipulated uh stipulations
between Council there's only been one
stipulated fact and that was the one
done today so if you want to submit a
jury instruction
on that one that that witness did not
did not see the accident I will
certainly read that
page five
fault defined we already
address the fault instruction
stay in control
trying to remember which instruction
that was
okay I'm looking at it it's on page 13
of plaintiff's instructions
this was based on the Summit County
ordinance
I'm assuming that if the if the
ordinance is adopted into that other
instruction that covers this one
okay
remember
so Christensen was asked about this
burger was asked about this but no one
laid the foundation that this is quote
the law
isn't that the courts isn't that what
the court does though
um
so in other words they it facts were
introduced it could be applied to the
law in this case it's the Summit County
ordinance I don't think a witness has to
testify what the law is in fact they
couldn't
so
did any witness even mention the term
Summit County ordinance I thought there
was but I don't know that that's
determinative for the reason I just
stated
I think there's no witness there's no
witness that testifies
that as to negligence either they just
testify as to the facts when the jury
decides if it fits negligence
right
my thought process is if if it's not
admitted
this is a civil claim so it's not like a
criminal matter where like the
definition of homicide is the law
I I guess I'm
I don't think all then then we just why
don't we give them the statute on an
inherent risks I mean
it seems like someone sort of has to
build build in
is a
immunity statute not a
a safety statute
I understand that's your position no I'm
talking sorry I was talking to council
okay so I've got I mean there's
extensive argument here by the
defendants I'll consider all of it on
this uh stay in control of instruction
maybe one more piece of information so
that that last Supreme Court case
Donovan versus Sutton right they
specifically did not decide as I recall
it
that uh
look to the look to the summary at the
end that's where Justice Peterson what
the holding is
failed to persuas that affects your
implicates section 316 is the second
restatement of torts even if we were to
adopt it so we leave that question for
another day
are you looking at the Appellate Court
decision or the Supreme Court thank you
for asking me that
Utah Supreme Court last sentence okay
to the extent that that
helps us like
not admit
into evidence the
the statutes I would
defer to it okay thank you
then there's an instruction downhill
skiers have the right of way
anything that you want to add to the
objection I mean in response to the
objection Mr Peterson
I have the objection here
your honor I think uh maybe two other
Witnesses referred to it including uh
in addition to bugger Graf and
Christensen
are you on it meaning are you on
instruction on page 14 downhill skiers
have right-of-way
so the plaintiff is asking for an
instruction on page 14 of their instru
of their proposed instructions downhill
skiers have right-of-way the defendant
on page seven of their objections have
listed their objection so do you have
any reply to their objection
that's correctly they they want to roll
or wrap in the skiing safely or staying
in control with the down hill skier
right of way and construction and I
think we'd prefer that they'd be
separate
we object to the
the Donovan inherent risk part of it
yeah
okay
under advisement next one
skiers Duty in the event of a collision
I think that's kind of wrapped up in the
what the Court decides on the ordinance
I think you're right your honor and
again this directed verdict tomorrow
morning is going to be on that issue
um core damages we covered on page nine
at the top
and collateral Source payments
um what what's the response to the
defendant's objection on the collateral
Source instruction
and I realized
is that a Emoji instruction it is yeah
do we have the uh Muji
and and you basically follow it in your
proposed instructions so we just want to
stick with the Muji here on okay I'll
take that under advisement
I have one sentence on it if you want
um is it more than you've already done
that would require me to know what I've
already done okay go ahead
I suspect in closing they're going to
say hey he incurred a lot of economic
damages but we're out of the kindness of
our heart because he was in the VA
system we're not we're not claiming
those
and I don't want them to do that in open
in closing are you going to argue we've
been over this a lot no we're not
planning on arguing that thank you so
pure non-economic damage
they've made it they I mean you
essentially made a Judicial admission
that you're not seeking we have
economics they could not make that
argument thank you
are you still requesting the collateral
Source instruction even though they're
they're not claiming
economic damage
so it's our we are objecting to
Collateral Source payment objection uh
is this correct they want it and we
don't
yeah why would we have it the whole
thing is discussing uh
economic damages that aren't being
claimed
you still want to maintain the
collateral source construction Council
plaintiffs
uh we'll defer to what uh well
yeah we think the Muji is appropriate if
if it is a concern that it's going to be
raised that
it's been an issue here we've had VA
records all through here so
yeah I think it's a useful instruction
your honor in case the defense
insinuates that uh we've got VA coverage
and
um
they did in their opening
I don't recall doing that I'm not going
to do it in closing
it's the insinuations that it and also
the assumptions by many people that owe
insurance or
retired military people or VA coverages
out there so we think it's a useful
instruction
your honor this does remind me my
opening I said he he is a vet he has
care through the VA his VA treating
providers assess them neurologically
neuropsychology wise and they found he's
uh average to above average in every
category none of that deals with like
collateral Source dollar amounts
it's no reference to that I think also
in he didn't pay anything
it's never come up
okay I've got the new totals on time if
you want to jot these on to that
spreadsheet I gave you to correct at the
end of day six
thank you
for the plaintiff it's 15 hours 19
minutes
for the defendant it's 14 hours 50
the defense went down
okay
moving on demonstrative exhibits I think
we already covered that I think you're
right
[Applause]
um
special verdict form I think I just
discuss that I think that covers it all
I think so you're wrong thank you
spoilation yes
um do you prefer that be filed by
Tweeting or email or all the parties
um
I guess at this point I I have no
preference I mean whatever you whatever
way you decide you want to do it Peter
if you do file it in the court docket
also email it so that it gets to me
faster yeah
if I make there was a filing or an email
that went out and it had the incorrect
email for me so I never got it it was
from the defense
so Steve and uh if you guys could make
sure you have the right email it's on
our pleading every pleading because
Jackie at Bob's office noticed and said
hey Lawrence you didn't get this because
they sent it to the wrong email it just
misspelled the first part of my email
address do you know who that was who
sent that
um I could find out it came through some
time earlier this morning I don't know
yeah I haven't done any emails this
morning but yes well it came through on
the like last weekend like Friday or
something and I never knew about it
because it didn't come to me that would
be very irritating
correct your correct email it's not all
the pleadings every pleading we've ever
filed okay I think it's l Bueller
sometimes the small L looks like an ion
it goes to my wife Isabel so that's why
I always try to capitalize the L
I promise you that was unintended